when an anomaly is first detected by an
SCP Foundation field agent it's up to
the foundation's mobile task forces to
tag and bag The Impossible entities
before they can do any more harm
sometimes these retrievals are
uneventful other times not so much
especially when they're dealing with
brutal forces of nature like
scp-096 also known as the shy guy a
creature that from the very first
interaction with the foundation had a
reputation for being dangerous and
needed to be feared a series of vague
sightings and mysterious disappearances
up in the frosty mountains of the Yukon
first Sparks the foundation's interest
when they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams Zulu 9A and Zulu 9B were
dispatched to secure and contain the
entity Zulu 9A took the lead in a heavy
duty Chopper equipped with 50 caliber
gau-19 heavy machine guns and carrying
an at4 anti-tank launch they were
prepared for anything or so they thought
as they established a visual on scp-096
while two clicks away from the target
they couldn't get a clear line of sight
on the creature but it appeared to be
stationary docile and was making no
attempt to Flay piece of cake right
little did they know that scp-096 was
just looking away from them if it was
facing towards them it'd be a whole
different Horror Story as 9A were about
to find out the team landed their
helicopter next to the creature and were
shocked to see that it was completely
naked in spite of the Sub-Zero
temperatures all around them the
creature was unnaturally thin as though
had been starved for weeks with bone
white skin and unnaturally long limbs
the team guessed that the creature's
arms must have been at least 1.5 meters
long but its docile nature and
insubstantial body mass gave the
impression that it would improve too
difficult to contain that is until they
saw its face Zulu 9a's Captain was the
Lone Survivor of the incident as he was
lucky enough to be looking away when the
creature turned towards his team the
rest of the squad ended up staring eye
to eye with scp-096 and from that moment
on wasn't docile anymore the creature
began to whimper then cry then SOB
uncontrollably in a way that sounded
eerily human this Sudden Change in
temperament startled the rest of zulu 9A
and they opened fire on the creature
under the hail of gunfire SCP p096
entered a murderous frenzy and began
tearing into the hapless Squad of
soldiers while its flesh and organs did
seem to take damage as a result of the
barrage of 50 caliber rounds from the
helicopter mounted machine guns its
skeletal structure remained intact and
it continued its Onslaught tearing the
team Lim from limb even after they blown
practically all the flesh from the
creature the at4 anti-tank launcher
proved equally ineffective at stopping
scp-096 while it was in attack mode it
was only after slaughtering the entire
team that had returned to its docile
State nobody knows exactly what the
creature did to Zulu 9A after the
gunfire started but no trace of the team
was left behind
Zulu 9B touched down soon after and with
a grave warning from the captain not to
look at the creature's face they were
finally able to subdue it a bag was
placed over scp-096's face which seemed
to soothe it enough to move it to a
nearby Foundation facility little did
they know they just obtained one of the
deadliest scps of all time and while it
may have been under lock and key for now
it seemed inevitable that it would get
out and cause more violence and Chaos
research and containment procedures for
the scp-096 were put under the command
of Dr Dan a senior researcher at the
site it was his job to find out exactly
what this being was capable of the more
he tested the more he realized that they
were dealing with something truly
terrifying disposable d-class Personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its Attack Mode just as it had during
the initial retrieval Mission
scp-096 went berserk when any of the
attending Personnel saw its face in this
stage it would enter a period of
considerable and Unstoppable distress
for one to two minutes covering its face
and wailing loudly when the period of
distress ended the creature would
mercilessly Slaughter every d-class that
had seen its face and just like with
Zulu 9A no trace of their bodies would
be left behind
Dr Den was horrified and intrigued by
this phenomenon the creature killed
anyone that saw its face directly but
could the same be said for indirect
depictions of the creature's face such
as images and videos Dr Dan was
desperate to find out more d-class
Personnel were brought in to test this
to frightening results Dr Dan found that
the creature did indeed still enter
Attack Mode when people saw pictures and
videos of scp-096's face the creatures
seemed to have an innate sense of when
people were viewing these
representations even when it should have
had no conceivable way of knowing it
didn't matter how far away or how many
barriers were in place between the
viewer and the creature the attack mode
would still activate and once it did it
seemed as though nothing could stop the
creature from hunting down the one who
saw its face with all this new data
special containment procedures were
devised to keep the creature safely
under lock and key its cell was a 5
meter by 5 meter by five meter airtight
steel queue fitted with Advanced
pressure sensors and Laser detectors to
ensure that scp-096 remained in itself
without risking anyone having visual
contact with the creature's face all
cameras and video equipment were
strictly forbidden and weekly checks for
any cracks or holes in the containment
cell were mandatory of course none of
this would stop the Creature if anyone
somehow saw its face in order to solve
that little problem Dr Dan would need to
continue his research
to find a method of subverting the
creature's deadly glance they needed to
know exactly what they were dealing with
but how could they when even a glance at
a photo or video of the being meant
certain death
a potential solution was proposed
creating an artistic representation of
the creature's face something that
hadn't yet been attempted but how would
they achieve such a fee simple they'd
procure a d-class prisoner with some
artistic talent and they found one who
had been a tattoo artist before becoming
a foundation guinea pig Dr Dan
formulated an ingenious plan for keeping
this d-class alive for long enough to
accurately draw an image of
scp-096's face you would be placed in a
bathosphere diving bell several
kilometers underwater and tens of
kilometers away from the containment
cell where the SCP was being held the
d-class was made to look at a photograph
of the creature's face and then
replicate that image in a pencil sketch
Dr Dan first confirmed that the
creature's Attack Mode is only activated
by the creature's face by having the
d-class look at a series of photos of
the scp's body parts one by one finally
finishing with its face the d-class
began drawing and even remarked on how
creepy the scp's facial features were
despite not knowing the Dudley contacts
meanwhile back in its containment cell
scp-096 sends someone viewing its face
and entered its inconsolable crying
State followed by its Attack Mode it
broke out of containment easily and
began making a b line for the d-class
traversing the miles between it and its
prey the d-class didn't know it as he
locked the finished drawing into a
separate autonomous submersible but he
was already dead
as the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface
scp-096 divd into the water and started
swimming down towards the artist minutes
later the bathysphere was breached
the d-class was torn to shrine
scp-096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team foxtrot 303a and
further testing on the drawing showed
that artistic representations of
scp-096's face were in fact harmless
from this experience we now know that
the creature has a gaunt face with
totally white eyes possibly indicating
blindness and a grossly extended jaw
nevertheless Dr Dan was adamant that
scp-096 was too dangerous to be left
alive and requested permission from the
upper echelons of the foundation to
terminate the creature by any means
necessary however the doctor's request
would fall on deaf ears until it all
started with a seemingly innocent image
while it's now been redacted for your
safety the blacks back inside the yellow
circle was once a minuscule image of
scp-096 taken unknowingly in the 1990s
by a semi-professional mountaineer one
day they were looking at Old photographs
when his eyes passed over the tiny Speck
without even noticing that he had seen
anything but as p096 noticed and began
entering its Attack Mode it tore through
its steel containment unit like tissue
paper causing the release of a nerve
agent that killed a number of attending
Foundation staff the monster then fled
the base and began pursuing its prey
with mobile task force Tau 1 and Hot
Pursuit Dr Alexey was helping to manage
the site where the SCP was contained was
in dismay over the situation Dr Dan was
out of the country at the time trying to
discover more about the creature's
Origins however he did leave the mobile
task force with a new secret weapon
against the rampaging Shy Guy project
scramble scramble were state-of-the-art
goggles featuring a new technology
created by Dr Dan which using artistic
Renditions of 096's facial features
could detect and scramble the features
of scp-096 into an unrecognizable form
preventing the normally deadly effect of
gazing upon its face in theory this
would allow MTF tal1 to engage safely
with 096 Once its prey had been
eliminated and bring it back into
containment but disaster struck on two
fronts first the praying question was
located in a population Center creating
the potential for a huge loss of life
and the second bigger problem was that
the scramble technology didn't work as
straight pixels of the creature's face
would reach the eyes of the task force
before the internal microprocessor had
time to scramble them the mission turned
into a death sentence as scp-096
slaughtered almost the entire task force
as well as a number of civilians in town
including an infant and its entire
family who was a Monumental disaster
made even worse by a final Revelation Dr
Dan and Dr Alexi had themselves
facilitated the entire Containment
Breach and allowed the resulting
Massacre to happen with Dr Dan hoping it
would be enough motivation for
foundation command to Green Light his
research into destroying the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing would be
worth the bloodshot his plan worked and
the SCP Foundation saw it his way
approving his request to neutralize SCP
096 however success comes at a cost for
Dr Dan once he figures out a way to
finally kill the creature though done in
his line of duty he himself will be
terminated by the foundation for his
crimes against humanity but considering
how much damage scp-096 is capable of
causing if it ever got to a major
population Center or even worse was ever
caught on camera and broadcast to a
worldwide audience the doctor himself
would likely deem his own death a
justifiable cost to this day the
foundation is researching ways to kill
the creature and they're still looking
for their Silver Bullet and the pressure
is on they hadn't known about the
seemingly innocent picture that sparked
the last containment breach the one
taken decades ago in which the shy guy
had only occupied four tiny pixels four
tiny pixels that resulted in multiple
innocent lives lost
so be careful where you look because who
knows how many other photos of the
creature are lurking up there photos
with an innocent dot in the background
your eyes glance over it not even
noticing the little blip until you hear
a distant wailing that seems to be
getting closer and closer and closer and
then it's already too late as you walk
down the halls of the SCP Foundation
site 19 speaking in the various windows
that the anomalies contained there you
might catch a glimpse of a dark figure
bent over a table tinkering away like an
artisan in his Workshop a vintage black
Apothecary bag sits next to him open and
if you stop and watch a while you'll see
him pull all manner of tools out of it
impossibly large tools things that
shouldn't fit in such a small bag a bone
saw an IV stand jars of fluorescent
liquids and needles the length of your
forearm you shouldn't be surprised this
is a place for impossible things after
all still it's a curious sight the
shadowy man working so diligently so
quietly focused singularly on his craft
whatever that might be only one thing
could distract him from his efforts you
he feels your Gaze on him and he looks
up dark eyes glittering from behind a
beaked ceramic mask he reminds you of an
illustration you once saw in a book
about the Black Death the gear the
plague doctors wore while treating
patients on their deathbeds hello he
greets you in a friendly heavily
accented voice his eyes crinkled beneath
the mask and if you could see his mouth
you know he'd be smiling how are you
today dear friend are you feeling quite
well he takes a step toward the window
stretching out one gloved hand and you
suddenly realize that you can't see
where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face
this is no ordinary man do you require
hell I can examine you he offers Palm
press flat against the glass a chill
runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on
his offer no matter how friendly he
seems how good his intentions may be you
wouldn't want to let the plague doctor
treat you he sat in his containment cell
fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the surface of his work
table back and forth listening to the
sound it made they had tried to
confiscate his table his tools the
guards had quickly learned that he had
more of them in his bag they tried to
take away his bag from him but well that
didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
Fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the morgue
for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would
come to speak with him talking of
cryptobiology and the pestilence he had
dedicated himself to fighting those days
were long gone he had hidden away pieces
of the corpses tissue samples and jars
of formaldehyde he could pull out when
the monotony became too much but the
days of fresh materials of enlightened
discourse with other men and women of
science were over
those days the chance to work with
others as he once had what had he done
wrong all he did was treat the sick sure
they didn't always understand their
illness didn't want to receive their
medicine but that wasn't a choice for
the patient to make that should have
been up to the physician perhaps they
didn't trust his expertise then see how
his work served the greater good like
those who watched Jonas Salk invent the
polio vaccine or Louis Pasteur with milk
of bacteria they were confused by the
advanced scientific practices and feared
that which they did not understand he
could forgive them for their ignorance
he was magnanimous that way if only they
would let him out of this infernal room
he could prove his work's Worth to them
he could cure them all begin a new era
of wellness and peace worldwide he
didn't exactly sleep but when he rested
on his little cot in the corner of the
room he dreamed of that future of a
world healed biased touch a knock at the
door stirred him from his reverie
someone someone was at the door of his
containment cell he glanced at the
little window and saw a guard there with
a tray of food he greeted the man with
an enthusiastic wave
sustenance he didn't require the food
for survival of course but it helped his
mind work more efficiently it reminded
him of a time before these fluorescent
lights and these same Four Walls of
crusty bread with fresh butter by the
banks of the sin the little slot opened
in the door and the tray was shoved
through there was bread just as he hoped
a small dish of butter pot of jam and a
cup of tea still seeming he picked up
the cup at first taking a deep breath ah
an herbal blend with fresh lavender
lovely he couldn't see the guard through
the window anymore but he called out to
him just the same thank you for the
Libations he still had his manners after
all even in confinement he wished he
could have gotten a better look at the
man seen the power of His complexion a
Tremor in his hand he thought he had
spotted sweat beating on his forehead
could he be ill the case required
further examination to be certain he
sighed clutching the cup of tea tighter
in frustration why wouldn't they just
let him
why must they scream at the sight of his
efforts flee from his instruments it
didn't seem fair still the pursuit of
science rarely was a glamorous one he
had learned as much over the centuries
one day though history would look back
on him kindly of this he could be
certain he was just settling in and
beginning to spread butter across the
admittedly stale bread when a horrible
sound shook him to attention he had
heard the noise before though he had
never seen its source it was an
ear-splitting scream a whale of pure
Agony like the sound of a wounded wild
animal he had heard many many screams
during his life from patients and those
who stood in the way of his work but
until he had been brought into custody
of the foundation he had never heard a
scream quite like this one it was pure
rage Devastation and suffering mixed
together wet with tears and loud enough
to rip through human vocal
whatever was crying out it was no mere
man more screams answered it and these
were very much human these sounds were
more familiar to him shrieks of pain of
fear of desperate but futile attempts to
escape then the meaty thought of bodies
falling to the floor of torn off limbs
hitting walls and windows a loud crash
and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the Halls
scientific curiosity got the better of
the doctor and he found himself moving
back to his little window face pressed
to the glass so hard his beak nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of
anything just guards running down the
hall weapons drawn he saw one of them
fire for The Gunshot ring out but what
was he firing at then he saw it a pale
blur darting past the door whatever it
was it didn't so much as Flinch when the
bullet ricocheted off its skin a long
thin arm crashed against the door
knocking the doctor backwards into his
work table he studied himself and and
climbed back to his feet taking in the
Damage Done to the door it was crumpled
in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it
was already gone from the sounds of
Chaos in the distance it had disappeared
around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of
the door to his containment cell it was
useless now hanging loose and open well
that was an invitation he was hardly
about to decline he grabbed his trusty
bag tossed his scalpel back inside and
set off to see what all the commotion
was it was easy enough to follow the
trail of blood Stark and Vivid red
against the white tile floor and the
sound of gunfire human screams and that
loud long painful whale he had heard
before he walked at a leisurely Pace
taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found
a mound of bodies guards and scientists
beaten and bloodied almost beyond
recognition it was quiet
save for one sound the sound of weeping
there in the corner huddled over with
its face to the wall was a pale thin
figure it shoulders heaving with the
force of its sobs this poor soul was
clearly in great distress it was a
peculiar sight hairless and white
distended arms wrapped around itself as
it cried excuse me the doctor cried out
to the pitiful creature are you all
right do you need assistance he didn't
answer it just continued to cry had
something so despondent been responsible
for this destruction the dozens of
corpses the smashed in walls the
crumbled doors and shattered Windows it
seemed impossible sure it was large and
looked strong but he had never seen a
monster cry before this couldn't be a
dangerous creature not when it was so
sad he would help it but first he would
attend to some of these bodies he sat
his bag on the ground and pulled out
several miles of liquid a set of
syringes and a variety of other surgical
tools he might need now after such a
long Hiatus he could resume his work in
a meaningful way he couldn't be certain
how long he worked Reviving these poor
souls and reconstructing their bodies as
the pale creature wept in the corner the
sobbing faded into the background for a
while becoming a kind of white noise as
he removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
One By One The Milky eyes fluttered open
rigor mortis stiff joints creaked into
motion sallow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need
to thank him with their words the work
was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature it didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the reborn man a
vial of thick black medicine give this
to the poor fellow in the corner please
it wasn't much but it should calm him
provide some relief from his Suffering
The Corpse nodded mouth hanging loose
and open and Eyeball dangling unseen
from the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial
to it it turned lifting its head and as
it locked eyes with the cured patient
something shifted in its face its mouth
opened wide
impossibly wide and a treat that same
terrible sound as before tears streamed
from its colorless eyes its arms shaking
with unbridled rage as its jaws locked
around the patient's head like a boa
constrictor in one fluid motion it
swallowed the revived manhole while the
doctor watched in shock he had been
wrong this was not an innocent creature
caught in the wrong place at the wrong
time this creature whatever it was was
deeply sick he had never seen such an
advanced aggressive case of the
pestilence he'd heard rumors of course
but never encountered it firsthand as a
doctor he had sworn to do no harm but in
a drastic situation drastic measures
have to be taken it was well known by
himself and the doctors at this
Foundation that he could cause any and
all biological functions in an organism
to cease with a single touch and so he
approached the creature arm outstretched
ready to administer that necessary touch
to protect the rest of his patients as
he approached the creature turned to him
its eyes wide and blank an endless
stream of Tears pouring from them
spilling onto the floor it shrieked
again mouth stretching wide enough to
engulf his entire head and ran toward
him at a break next speed I am so sorry
you are not well the doctor said simply
as his hand pressed to the creature's
chest as soon as the tough hide of the
doctor's hand which the uninformed might
mistake for gloves made contact with the
unpigmented skin of the Beast its eyes
closed its muscles went slack and it
collapsed to the ground with a mighty
thud the doctor paced around the Fallen
creature taking in the sight then
something strange caught his eye the
creature's chest still Rose and fell was
it his imagination he checked its pulse
and thought it was slow and faint and
though was slow and faint it was very
much present the creature was still
alive it had merely been rendered
unconscious by his touch rather than
completely deceased curious very curious
indeed he muttered perhaps there were
comorbidities present other infections
aside from the pestilence which rendered
the creature unnaturally strong
resilient to the usual courses of
treatment what would cause these
abilities this intense aggression it
seemed to be brought on whenever someone
looked at the entity's face if only he
studied psychology more the science of
the mind and its inner workings since he
had no experience with therapy nor was
he certain this creature could
communicate using language at all there
was only one way to find out more about
how this creature's brain worked he
would have to take it apart and see for
himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell it required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive Limbs and dragged the limp body
through the Halls once back in a
familiar environment his work table
ready and waiting the doctor instructed
his assistance to place the new patient
on the table it was a bit small unable
to accommodate the creature's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official Foundation Laboratory he risk
discovery and subsequent Interruption so
it would have to suffice first he set up
an IV stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the
creature's skin was nearly translucent
now that he could be certain the
creature would not wake during surgery
he could make the first incision scalpel
be held out of hand and his favorite
surgical blade was placed in it by one
of the helpful patients thank you he
slid the scalpel along the hairline of
the creature or where the hairline would
be if it weren't completely bald once
the scalp was removed he set it aside
for later when it could be reattached
bonsa please he held out his hand again
and again his assistant gave him the
proper tool this however was when things
got strange the doctor had always been a
Deft hand at cutting he'd once even
received tutelage from the great Robert
Liston but no matter how hard he tried
to saw it never left a scratch on the
creature's skeleton naturally this was
somewhat frustrating he wanted to study
the creature's brain tissue to get a
sense for what was going up there
neurologically and he couldn't do that
if it was impossible to saw off the
creature's cranial cap he blunted two of
his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he'd learned while studying the
funerary practices of the ancient
Egyptians he produced a long curved Hook
from his bag and inserted it up the
creature's nasal passage with some fine
maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by
piece via the nasal passage but one
makes do all that was left was to sew
the skin of the creature's head back
into place it was mid-stitch when a
voice interrupted his careful work
nearly making him drop the needle hey
what are you doing he looked up to find
a guard aiming a gun at his face excuse
me I am in surgery at the moment please
do not interrupt he admonished the guard
but the man did not listen or love lower
his weapon in fact he shouted something
into the radio code words the doctor
didn't recognize then he fired a bullet
into the skull of the patient standing
at his side how dare you the doctor
cried readying himself to confront the
guard but it was too late dozens of
other guards were swarming the room and
neutralizing his assistance some in
hazmat suits grabbed his arms and pulled
him away from the creature on the
operating table no matter how hard he
fought or how loudly he protested then
something incredible happened something
wonderful the creature opened its eyes
and sat up it looked directly at the
guard closest to it and the two saw one
another's faces the guard tensed
preparing for the worst but nothing came
the creature simply stared Placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing of Flesh
no mouth opening wider and wider to
swallow the manhole I did it the doctor
shouted overcome with Elation I cured
you now Begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the
shockingly calm creature away back to
its containment cell the doctor's door
was repaired and he was returned to his
state of captivity but he never forgot
the patient he helped that day and how
marvelous it felt to do such a good deed
meanwhile
scp-096's brain regrew within the hour
and caused another massive Containment
Breach murdering a variety of
researchers and guards but the staff
agreed not to tell scp-049 about any of
this better to just let him have this
one he really seemed like he needed the
win a very strange anomaly sits in a
humanoid containment cell in the minimum
security weighing of sight 17. he walks
talks and looks like a man but
everything else is convoluted in a
question mark this is scp-343 who like
his namesake God is likely to cause
arguments whenever he's brought up is he
the creator of all all that exists the
basis for the abrahamic faiths or is he
a pretender a reality warper with
immense power and pre-dilection towards
delusion a courtesian of the House of
maladrog Matthew Methuselah Yahweh who
knows really it depends on who you ask
and which stories you choose to believe
and few people enjoy a good story more
than scp-343 himself if one day you take
the time to visit him in his room and
ask him to reveal a page in the long
book of his personal history he might be
kind enough to tell you a story a story
like this of an encounter with something
monstrous that few others could hope to
survive meeting face to face rewind a
few thousand years nobody knows how many
exactly God as he chooses to dub himself
walked across the cracked ground on worn
sandals had been some time since he'd
seen an animal around here and even
longer since he'd see being a human
being not that this bothered him he'd
never been bothered by his own company
on a long walk like this of course he
could have sped up time or teleported
but where was the fun in that he was a
tourist in the world of sensation of
experience of Flesh bone dirt blood and
Sand after all where's the fun in
creating a whole universe if you can't
drop in now and then to visit and do as
the Romans do not that the Romans would
be around for another few thousand years
even Atlas must occasionally shift the
weight of the globe from his shoulders
for a jaunt around the cosmic
neighborhood and whatever passes for
fresh air in the vacuum God whistled the
tune to himself it was a craggy
mountainous region he'd found himself in
the distant Peaks had Frosted caps a
breathtaking place where many truly had
their breaths taken away how humans will
so happily risk their lives to do
something extraordinary it never ceased
to amaze him his stomach
oh how he enjoyed that sensation one of
the funny little quirks of this human
form that he weaved for himself it was
no reason to be concerned if memory
served from his last trip through the
area a few decades before there was a
Friendly Village not far from here they
had always accepted him as a general
stranger having no knowledge of his true
power God had always believed that a
person's goodness is defined by how they
treat those from whom they had nothing
to gain so it caused him great concern
as he approached the village and saw
great plumes of smoke Rising into the
sky he was so shocked by this that he
could decide to break his rule about
walking as a man in case there was still
some way he could help with a snap of
his fingers he disappeared and
reappeared in the center of The
Village's Town Square total devastation
huts and houses had been torn asunder
broken weapons lay on the ground some
places were on fire others smeared with
streaks of blood like some terrible
battle had have occurred here but
something was wrong no bodies not one
from defender or assailant How could a
thriving Village be so thoroughly
destroyed and not leave a single corpse
it was an act so bizarre and depraved
that it left even God puzzling that was
another downside of his human form here
on Earth he didn't have access to True
omniscience How could a mere human mind
Bound by the constraints of linear time
ever truly comprehend the total of
existence even attempting to do that
here would melt the brain of his human
body in its skull and leave it dribbling
out of his nose and ears instead he
chose to walk around the ruins of the
village and investigate firsthand arrows
and broken Spears and swords littered
the ground some buildings were
demolished but there were no tracks or
stray projectiles that could suggest the
presence of Siege weapons now these
buildings look like they were ripped
apart some even still had claw marks
what terrible Beast could have set upon
this town and done this then he heard a
voice quiet and pleading beneath some
nearby rubble a Survivor he rushed over
to the pile and evaporated it with a
thought underneath a feeble old man
covered in stone dust was quivering God
helped him up and guided him into one of
the few remaining Huts still standing in
the village they both took seats God
held up two hands cradling empty space
two cups suddenly occupied that space
both filled with warm healing tea he
passed the old man one of the cops while
sipping from his own he asked the old
man if he'd seen what had happened the
old man told him no he hadn't seen
anything in decades he'd been rendered
blind in his youth little did either of
them know that very blindness was the
only reason he was the sole survivor of
the massacre the blind man told God that
one of the villages Scouts had gone up
into the mountain with a small Hunting
Party the group was gone for days until
one of the members the youngest among
them returned weeping frostbitten and
covered in blood he said that his
friends had been killed by a beast in
the mountains something that almost
looked like a man but terribly wrong and
its face it's awful awful face he would
never forget it he was just lucky to
escape with his life when the others
were torn apart but when the young man
returned he'd brought the shadow of
death with him it was a curse that
doomed the entire Village men women and
children to a terrible fate and that
fate was upon them a mere hour after the
Survivor had returned of course there
were gaps in The Blind Man's
understanding given he was lacking one
of his major senses but the sounds he
could describe with perfect clarity it
was faint and distant at first that
awful well and the Galloping hands and
feet thundering against the ground
faster than any horse could move getting
closer and closer another villager saw
it approaching and screamed then it was
upon them the villagers screamed but it
screamed louder always wailing and
shrieking and sobbing like a monster
crawling Straight Up From Hell people
tried to fight it by the sounds of it
the blind man with teary blank eyes
recalled the sounds of Eros knocking and
swords clashing against something but
even their greatest warriors had
screamed and died those who saw it and
tried to flee and hide were slaughtered
all the same soon enough there were only
two sounds left in the village the
monster and the blind man both weeping
he didn't understand why it never took
him it wasn't fair it took everything
else to leave him here alive when
everyone and everything he'd ever known
was destroyed was a greater punishment
than even death after killing all of
these Innocents the monster had simply
wandered off to the mountains again the
sound of its quiet sobs getting smaller
and smaller until it was gone altogether
God comforted the blind man as he wept
for the loss of all his loved ones he
told the blind man that he would venture
up to the mountains himself and confront
the creature on its own territory and at
the very least find out why it had done
this terrible thing but first he must
relocate the blind man to a safer place
he placed a hand on the Blind Man's
shoulder and he vanished he would appear
in another Friendly Village miles away
God sent a silent message into the minds
of every villager take good care of this
man he has undergone [ __ ] as you can to
even imagine
your kindness will be rewarded later for
that you have my promise God's side and
turned his tired eyes to the distant
mountains a monster lurked up there
perhaps one of his own Creations or
maybe a Corruption of one of his
Creations either way whatever existed
without his knowledge existed without
his consent and he intended to know of
the beast in the mountains though given
what he'd seen already he didn't expect
to receive a warm welcome from this
murderous demon miles away up in the
mountains the creature licked the blood
from its cracked lips it looked like it
might have once been a human being or
something that aspired to humanity or
mocked it with its very existence it was
a huge gangling Beast skin aliblaster
eyes empty and soulless dribbling
rivulets of burning tears down a hideous
gaunt face it crawled into the Frozen
mouth of a cave with great icicle fangs
wheezing and weeping all it ever wanted
was to be alone why did they have to
keep interfering didn't they know what
happened all the terrible things they
made it do the creature curled its long
gangly body into the fetal position
scratching great ruts into the sides of
its bald Cranium with long sharp fingers
Terrible Things terrible terrible things
and then there was a brilliant flash
just a few feet away the monster was
surprised it turned to see a figure
silhouetted in the mouth of the cave he
wore sandals and thin robes his eyes
glowed with the kind of power that the
monster didn't recognize this stranger
stared at the monster without an ounce
of fear in his heart he stared right
into its eyes unwavering no no no no no
no no no no he could feel it again the
rage bubbling up deep down a cauldron of
seething anger it hated the feeling like
being lowered into a vat of molten metal
unspeakable fire and pain coursing
through every vessel it began to weep
and scream while the stranger in the
cave mouth just watched not moving a
muscle do you know who I am
The Stranger asked with a deep voice
that betrayed almost infinite power
knowledge and wisdom but it wouldn't
change the outcome here the monster
bounded at him at speeds that wouldn't
be seen again until jet planes and
bullet trains are invented Millennia
into the future its jaws were hanging
impossibly wide fangs born its arms
extended and deadly claws ready to
strike but before those terrible hands
could close around the stranger he
vanished the monster stumbled and rolled
across the snow confused what trickery
was being used here I'll take that as a
no
said the voice from behind him you are
to show your father some respect more
respect than you gave to those poor
people down in the village at least
seething the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness
of the cave staring at him but the Beast
didn't have the capacity for awe or holy
Terror only violence boundless Limitless
Unstoppable violence it darted towards
the stranger again trying to strike him
somehow it was like fighting an empty
robe not a single one of its deadly
strikes seemed to hit the stranger the
stranger leaped backwards putting some
space between himself and the monster
but still not breaking a sweat he
breathed in deeply then exhaled the
breath came out like a mighty typhoon
shocking even the monster with its
sudden force it was blown backwards a
leaf in the wind until its Long Claws
dug into the ground and anchored it in
place the stranger gave a wry smile at
this impressed my mind or certainly a
tenacious one aren't you
he said perhaps we can talk for a little
while instead of fighting I want to know
why you killed all those people
no answer the Beast roared its Mighty
limbs pounding into the ground as it
closed the gap between itself and The
Stranger in fractions of a second it
would kill him rent him destroy him just
like all the others he'd left it no
choice suddenly the ground below it
seemed to give way the creature was
confused he looked down to see that the
ancient stone Below had somehow taken on
the properties of a liquid and it was
sinking the Beast panicked and it began
to thrash it was a strong swimmer but it
didn't expect to need to swim here the
shock was too much and soon the ground
submerged it entirely muffling its
terrible Roars and shrieks and just like
that the ground was solid again trapping
the Beast inside the stranger stepped
forward and looked at the ground a much
needed timeout
he said you do yourself no good
struggling like this despite its
terrible capacity for evil God couldn't
help but admire the beast at least on
the level of construction it was so
pared down so unburdened a killer to the
core but seemingly unkillable had he
made this creature billions of species
in the species those in turn had created
through billions of years of breeding
and evolution and somewhere along the
line this thing happened it was easy
even for the universe's Creator to lose
track of some of the tinier variables
and in the grand scheme of things even
this monster was still a tiny variable
but right here right now it was still
one hell of a problem the ground rumbled
below God cracks formed the mountain
peak shook God raised an eyebrow
genuinely impressed as the monster
ripped free of its Stone prison and
re-entered The Fray it roared and
screams still its blank eyes fixed on
him his skeletal body throbbed and
heaved with power unlike any other
creature in nature it was almost like
the longer their conflict went on the
more energized the Beast became God's
side all those poor villagers they never
stood a chance against this monster it
lunged for him even faster and stronger
than before he teleported out of the way
in the nick of time and the Beast claws
cleaved through a nearby cave wall
effortless God materialized nearby but
he didn't have time to speak the Beast
lunged again and again and again every
time he reappeared the Beast went for
him with impossible speed deciding to
widen the playing field God teleported
to the top of the mountain the creature
somehow sensing his presence vaulted
upwards and tunneled through the roof of
the cave bursting out of the ground in
front of God who was floating just
slightly off the ground it would be wise
of you to stop
God carefully entoned all this time you
know I've been going easy on you you
don't want to find out what the wrath of
God looks like
storm clouds were gathering above Mighty
Thunder roared across the sky the Beast
was undeterred it roared and galloped
towards God and God in turn called down
a response a volley of lightning the
likes of which the world has never seen
before or since struck down on the
charging monster the sudden white flash
could Sting the eyes from miles away the
monster shrieked from the blast feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and
atomized in the sheer heat of the
electricity around it it could smell
itself cooking the lightning blast only
lasted for a few seconds but for the
Beast it felt like eternity when the
onslaught stopped the air was still
heavy with electrical potential God
stared down at the black Scorch mark on
the side of the mountain where the
creature had been standing all the snow
within a mile had been evaporated by the
blast it was a raw display of the power
of nature that would make even Zeus
tremble in his sandals and yet there was
still movement some things started to
get up from the burnt patch where
nothing should be Left Alive a blackened
skeleton rising shakily from the ash but
still very much alive as it started to
Rise new flesh began growing over its
bones little by little even God was
astonished by the sight of it he'd never
seen a creature cling so ardently to
life in spite of having truly
unsurmountable power amassed against it
it was up against God and still it
fought the monster tottered on its
freakishly long limbs still disoriented
unusually staggered for a creature
driven by such single-minded violent
purpose when enough of its face grew
back to do so it began to weep and SOB
again tears streaking down its terrible
face looking at this creature after all
of this God couldn't help but feel a new
emotion pity he lowered himself to the
ground and approached the creature like
none had ever done before he gathered it
up into his arms and he held it feeling
its heaving wretched sobs against him
the Beast was in so much pain he could
feel it radiating from within speak
martial God said in a soft fatherly
voice and for the first and only time
the monster spoke
unwanted people
that was all it managed to choke out
before devolving back into
unintelligible Babble but it was enough
enough for God to understand its pain he
did not know if it would be right to
change the monster's nature is it ever
right to truly change anyone's nature
but it was within his almost Limitless
power to granted one reprieve from pain
he settled the beast in the snow below
him it was quiet and still and God said
unto the Beast rest now child
rest for thousands of years
I hope only that when you eventually
awaken you feel differently
and so another story from the catalog of
scp-343 of course it leaves us with
certain questions Chief among them being
is it true did 343 and 096 have this
chance encounter long ago or is this
just another tall tale from an anomaly
who fancies himself a deity we have our
truth and you have yours let us know
what you believe Down Below in the
comments what do you do when the sun
turns wrong when light which once
represented life joy and warmth becomes
a symbol of death and destruction do you
hide inside shudder the windows keep out
the light by any means necessary do you
Retreat underground where the sun's Rays
cannot penetrate burrowing into the dark
in the cold do you simply give yourself
to it accepting that there is no
escaping something so vast so far
reaching as sunlight itself and allow
yourself to be lost in the end of all
things
we've covered this possibility before
scp-001 when daybreaks or SD locks
proposal it's difficult to know what any
given person might do in such harrowing
circumstances after all we have always
learned to love the light and fear the
darkness it turns our very understanding
of reality upside down to have that
Paradigm shifted the dark becoming
safety and the light becoming death the
source of all life on Earth of all
warmth transforming in an instant from
the Sun as we know it to an apollyon
class SCP that melts all living
organisms that cross into its gaze but
what about a being that has always
feared the light something that
prioritizes Solitude and never ever
wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a
look at what happens when Daybreak meets
a familiar face even if a constantly
hidden one SCP
3096
scp-096 or the shy guy is something of a
celebrity around here it is a humanoid
creature with long distended arms pale
skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is
only one thing above all else that this
entity desires for no one to see its
face when someone views its face it
flies into an uncontrollable rage and
seems to have no other option but to
destroy the person who has seen it so it
is unlikely that a creature so intent on
Solitude would be in much Danger from
the transformed sun in fact it might
even be a positive thing and for some
time it was with so many human beings
gone reduced to gelatinous masses with
no desire but to Slither around in the
ghoulish sunlight and merge with one
another there were fewer people to
observe his face than ever he could stay
inside and know with almost complete
certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at
him and there were no more visitors
researchers poking and prodding that
might sneak a look at his face and so he
stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world
turned upside down the masses of Flesh
that once were humans did not concern
him as they never looked at his face all
he did was stay in his room and never go
outside the outside frightened him
terribly though he was not concerned
with the deadly sunlight or the
possibility of it melting him as it had
so many others he was much more afraid
that someone some unlikely Survivor
clinging to their original life might
look at him that they might see his face
that was simply too distressing to risk
he would much rather stay alone in his
old cell weeping softly in the shadows
one day though we couldn't say how many
days after the end of things that had
been he was weeping alone in his former
cell the days blurred together spent the
same way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his
sobs and the sloshing sounds of the
creatures outside a woman's voice cut
through it was faint but he could make
out what she was saying she was calling
out for help asking if anyone had any
food or fresh water the sound was
getting louder closer accompanied by the
disconcerting thump of her footsteps she
was coming down the hall as much as it
could be called a hall anymore she was
coming towards his room to disrupt his
miserable peace he heard her steps cross
the threshold of his room and her voice
broke into a terrified scream no doubt
at the unexpected sight of a pale naked
creature weeping in the corner of what
she expected to be an empty room
startled by the first loud sound he'd
heard in a long time in a world that had
mostly been silent since the initial
outpouring of agonized Screams had faded
into the soft slap of Flesh and slime on
the ground he turned around he shouldn't
ordinarily he wouldn't but he couldn't
stop himself there he saw a woman wide
eyes filled with tears face streaked
with dirt a small child next to her
holding her hand and clinging to her leg
just as he saw the woman she saw him she
saw his face anger boiled over inside of
him and he let out a scream wild Primal
and filled with inhuman rage she could
not be looking at him seeing his face he
couldn't let her the woman ran with a
child in tow panicked by the wild Roar
in the sight of him standing up right
before her the anger faded as she left
his sight making her way down the hall
into the stairs but then he remembered
she had seen his face he could not let
her leave it was time to do something he
never thought he'd have to do again hunt
his heightened senses picked up the
sound of muffled footsteps coming up
through the floor below him she was
downstairs just beneath the floor where
he was standing his instincts kicked in
and his body moved almost of its own
accord he lifted his long long arms
above his head and drove his hands down
into the floor it was weakened by the
ravages of the elements and time and
crumbled under his unnatural strength he
dug his claws into the plaster tearing
it apart and cracking it into pieces he
pushed his claws in deeper and deeper
until he could feel them breaking
through the other side he pulled the
floor apart until the hole was wide
enough to fit through then dropped down
to the room below he spotted the woman's
back fleeing through the door just as he
landed she was getting away he tore
after her ripping through concrete and
steel destroying everything in his path
in a Mad Dash for the object of his rage
he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her
shoulder at him her face a mask of pure
Terror she knew just as he knew that
there was no Escape in sight in his
single-minded obsession and her
desperation to escape from him neither
of them noticed that she had run so far
and so carelessly that she was now
outside the building she had crossed
from the Shadows into the harsh light of
the Sun the woman's eyes widened in Grim
understanding of her fate he could only
watch helplessly as her body began to
succumb to the vicious Rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was
closest to the Sun her head was the
first to go her nose drooped like hot
wax dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face and landed on the ground
with a sickening Splash her eyes were
next popping out of their sockets and
hanging loose and Limp on her cheeks and
dangling from Cinema strands she tried
in vain to stuff them back into place
but they squished in her hands like over
ripe fruit she attempted to run into the
comparative safety of the ruined
building but her feet were already
beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the
pavement her legs crumbled beneath her
and she collapsed to the ground her face
leaving a trail of gelatinous Flesh as
it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the
darkness but her arms were melting into
the dirt mixing with it into a horrible
red mud she let out a last scream of
Agony but the sound turned to a thick
gurgle as her lips fused together and
her mouth melted into nothingness he
watched it all sobbing and roaring in
frustration she was gone and he would
never get the satisfaction of ending her
The Infernal son had stolen her from him
now she was nothing but a Shadow like
the rest of the humans had become long
ago he heard the sound of a soft SOB
behind him a tiny human voice he turned
looking for the source there was the
little girl he had almost forgotten
about her she was calling out for her
mother and crying and she was looking
right at him right at his face he waited
for the anger to overtake him but
instead there was nothing why wasn't he
angry she was looking at his face so why
then he realized her eyes were on him
but she did not see him she was blind
she approached the creature her arms
outstretched following the sound of his
crying she touched his hand with her own
tiny fingers so small and fragile and
asked Mommy then he felt something he
had never felt before tenderness care a
desire to protect this tiny innocent
being it was the first time he had ever
felt warm ever felt anything but sadness
anger or fear overcome with this
softness he wrapped his arms around the
child and hugged her clothes she hugged
him back tightly and the room went quiet
as they both stopped crying from that
day on they became a family of sorts
they lived together and he took care of
her she didn't know what he looked like
and had no idea he might be something to
fear to her he was safety he was home
for the first time in his long awful
life he felt like a Human Instead of a
monster he would scavenge food for her
bring her fresh water lay down stolen
blankets and pillows so she would have a
soft place to rest he even found her a
ratty worn teddy bear amongst the rubble
and gave it to her as a gift she
clutched it to her chest and thanked him
and for once his tears were those of joy
in this cursed World they had found
something like happiness in one another
he knew he would protect her no matter
what then one day everything changed the
creature and the little girl were
playing in the abandoned sight making up
little games together when he took a
break to look out at the window and
monitor their surroundings outside the
evil Red Sun waited when he turned back
the little girl was gone one of the
shadowy creatures once human was
imitating his voice to lure her away he
could hear it in the distance and her
tiny footsteps following it he chased
after her the only thing he had ever
loved and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light she screamed as one
of her arms began to melt in the light
and he knew what he had to do he grabbed
her and pulled her back inside using his
body to Shield her from the horrible
Rays as he wept over her his tears
stopped her body from melting any
further but his body continued to fall
apart it was too late for him he ran as
far as he could once he transformed he
did not want to end up hurting the girl
he ran until his legs melted away and he
could not run anymore he had reached the
shoreline and stared out at the ocean
unable to move anymore he screamed a
final time in agony in heartbreak in
mourning for the happiness he had
finally found and now would lose but at
least he knew as his eyes melted away
and he was nearly gone that the girl
would be safe and then he was gone and
the world was quiet the day-to-day
routine of Dr gears consisted of a few
constants piping hot cups of black
unsweetened coffee plain dry wheat toast
the soothing sounds of his favorite
white noise machine and the endless
Carousel of experiments with scp-914 not
that he was complaining he was perfectly
content to spend his time supervising
one of the few anomalies he crossed
paths with on a regular basis that was
unlikely to kill or maim him in any way
not that the Clockworks hadn't produced
its fair share of unpredictable results
over the years of extensive testing it
had definitely offered up more than a
few surprises and anyone who knew Dr
gears knew that he was not especially
fond of surprises Dr bright had
attempted to throw a surprise birthday
party for the man once but when he
turned on the lights and fired the
confetti cannon all Dr gears did in
response was give a deep sigh and say
really Jack you're making a spectacle of
yourself still he had resigned himself
long ago to the fact that supervising
the experiments with scp-914 meant
witnessing some truly unpredictable
outcomes how could he forget the time
researcher Blas tested an incandescent
light bulb on the setting very fine and
the Machine spat out an anthropomorphic
humanoid light bulb that spoke in German
accented English and claimed to be
Thomas Edison himself this was of course
impossible as historical records surely
would have indicated if Thomas Edison
was a walking talking light bulb rather
than a human man The Imposter was
eventually incinerated after its
presence became too irritating to ignore
and then there was the time researcher
Thompson filled out a Dungeons and
Dragons character sheet and placed it
into the machine on the setting very
fine the output produced was a sheet of
paper promoting the previously
non-existent tabletop role-playing game
fear in the foundation whenever a person
read the paper they would suddenly find
themselves in an out of Body Experience
where they were inside the game's World
which contained several characters
related to the SCP Foundation as well as
items and locations based on real world
counterparts a subject in this state
would only snap back to reality after
winning or dying in the game researcher
Jacobson were all the one on stealth and
saw scp-096's face in the game and was
later found dead in the anomalous item's
storage Wing there was no shortage of
foundation staff trying to use the
machine for personal gain too Dr
naysmith placed his credit card inside
on the setting very fine using it to
produce a card covered in unidentified
corporate insignias and reading rank
aleph infinite money privileges when Dr
Coltrane issued a written warning Dr
Naismith took that warning and then
placed it into the machine on the same
setting producing a piece of official
documentation from the o5 council in
support of his infinite money privileges
Junior researcher Summers attempted to
use scp-914 in a misguided attempt at
self-improvement placing not an object
but herself in the intake Booth before
running the machine on the setting very
fine it cleared her skin lengthened her
hair and improved her figure this was of
course in violation of several employee
guidelines and she was promptly
dismissed after emerging from scp-914 Dr
Veritas left a note in the experiment
log following this incident reading by
the time we realized what she was
actually doing it was too late to stop
her needless to say she's since been
terminated and I hope I don't need to
tell you all not to do that again and
with that the guideline was clear no one
was permitted to use scp-914 for
personal gain or to change anything
about themselves potential complications
were too risky not to mention the
conflicts of interest that would be
introduced into what should be an
impartial research process as scientific
objectivity's biggest fan Dr gears
couldn't agree more so as he settled in
for the day's round of tests he intended
to keep a watchful eye on things and
ensure that no funny business would take
place he didn't have much reason for
concern as his colleague Dr Bonita
prepped her research materials she was
working with two items a small replica
of Michelangelo's sculpture of David and
a sealed envelope containing something
that was to be handled with Extreme
Caution a photo
of
scp-096's face she planned to place the
items inside on the very fine setting in
an attempt to see what result might be
produced from combining an ideal of
traditional beauty standards with the
image of a creature that felt such
profound shame and distress as its own
appearance that it would destroy anyone
who looked at its face like any good
scientist Dr Bonita wanted to remove any
unnecessary variables from her
experiment so as she placed her items
inside the intake Booth she slowly
delicately unsealed the envelope she
wanted to put the picture inside by
itself without the extra element of the
envelope potentially complicating things
unfortunately like Marie Curie slowly
unintentionally poisoning herself with
her own research materials she didn't
truly understand the danger of what she
held in her hands just as she was
setting the photograph down her eyes
flickered to the image before she could
stop herself before she could even look
away or squeeze her eyes shut she caught
a glimpse of the things she should never
scps or
sixes
he gasped and slammed the photograph
down but she
seen sound of an inhuman shriek coming
from across the facility signaled that
she was right it was coming for her and
nothing in the world could stop in a
containment cell on the other side of
the facility Foundation staff were
horrified as they heard The Telltale
scream of an enraged
scp-096 the pale Finn creature once
huddled in the corner silently had
stretched to its full height of 2.38
meters and was screaming sobbing wailing
and gibberish and beginning to tear its
way out of its chamber guards tried
their best to subdue The Entity firing
their weapons at it but the bullets did
nothing to damage the creature's pale
flesh or stop its movements it ripped
through the steel Cube that contained it
and knocked the guards out of its way
with one swipe of its unnaturally long
arms sending them careening into a
nearby wall fortunately for them scp-096
only knocked them unconscious it didn't
stop to harm them further as it had a
more important goal in
find the person who had seen its face
and Destroy them as the alarm blared
signifying a high Threat Level
containment reach
scp-096 Lopes down the hall toward Dr
Bonita in s
Dr gears had not spotted Dr Bonita's
grave mistake and had no idea what had
triggered the alarm he was hearing he
stepped away from the observation window
turning his attention to the crisis that
was clearly happening somewhere else in
the facility meanwhile Dr Bonita was
panicking she saw her life flash before
her eyes the certainty of impending doom
that was coming for her and coming fast
all because of one brief error in
judgment what could she do there was
nowhere to hide no way she could run
away fast enough unless if she managed
to lure 096 into the intake booth and
start the machine while the creature was
inside maybe it would transform into
something less intent on tearing her
limb from limb it was a risky move and
one that could jeopardize her position
at the foundation but she couldn't very
well keep her job if she was dead so it
seemed like it just might be worth a
shot a primal Roar of Agony Fury
interrupted her thoughts and she knew
that scp-096 was moments away from
breaking down the door and getting its
hands on her she would have to move fast
with a screeching grind of metal on
metal
scp-096 wrenched the door off its hinges
and barreled into the room in its search
for the person who had seen its face it
ran toward the silhouette of Dr Bonita
standing just at the entrance to the
intake Booth she tucked and rolled out
of the way just as the monster entered
the
the door automatically slides shut
behind it it is scp-096 rattled the door
and tried to free itself she turned the
knob to very fine with every ounce of
strength and speed she had there was a
ding of a small Bell and the Machine
word to life as the objects inside were
refined Dr Bonita had no idea what would
be waiting for her in the output Booth
but she could only hope that her
last-ditch effort had managed to save
her life in the fog of panic she briefly
felt an itch of scientific curiosity too
what would become of a being like
scp-096 in a machine as strange and
wonderful as scp-914 what would the
addition of the statue do to it as a
door to the outtake Booth slid open
Steam poured out it appeared her
questions would soon be answered
cautiously in spite of herself Dr Bonita
called out hello no one answered but she
heard the sound of footsteps slow and
careful as a figure emerged from the
Mist she covered her mouth
her eyes wide dear God she whispered and
awe standing in front of her with pale
smooth skin and the same imposing
stature was the most beautiful man she
had ever seen why dark eyes Shone under
thick sculpted eyebrows under the eyes
an aqualine nose full pouty lips a
strong sharp jawline his head was topped
with a tangle of lustrous dark curls it
was the kind of hair she had only seen
flowing in the Wind on the covers of the
romance novels she wanted desperately to
buy but was too embarrassed to be seen
purchasing his physique was well
statuesque like the build of the very
Michelangelo sculpture she had placed
into the machine just moments ago there
was no other way to say it he was
handsome despite still being a little
lanky and nine feet tall he peered at
her curiously towering over her in a way
that had been terrifying in his former
shape but now made her heart skip a beat
in entirely different way hi was all she
could think to say was she blushing she
shook her head snapping herself out of
it she was a scientist damn it not some
giddy school girl passing notes in class
this was an incredible achievement
something she would need to study
thoroughly and she very much wanted to
study him thoroughly nope no time for
that she needed to write up a report to
inform her superiors to try her best not
to lose her job over this she had to
remain professional I the man that had
once been or perhaps still was as cp096
spoke oh you you can talk Dr Bonita
laughed in Surprise the man's brow
furrowed his Newfound ability to speak
was a surprise to him too it seemed yes
I can what happened to me yeah stumbling
over his words slightly getting used to
the feeling of them you ran into the
machine she gestured to scp-914 I'm not
exactly sure to be honest but you're
very different now he nodded I feel
different I feel calm he sighed the
relief playing on his face before a
shadow of sadness fell over him I don't
think I have to hurt anymore I I'm sorry
for what I did before Dr Bonita did not
know what to say how do you respond when
something you've been studying from afar
been horrified and fascinated by an
equal measure looks at you with a new
beautiful face and apologizes for all
the harm it caused this whole experience
was so surreal she might think she was
dreaming if she didn't work at a place
that was one long waking dream or
nightmare depending on the day Dr Bonita
there's been a Containment Breach are
you all right Dr gears had returned to
the room taking in the sight of the
destruction left in 096's way I'm fine
she called to him and he followed her
voice into the room then stopped at the
site of the transformed anomaly
I don't have time for whatever this is I
trust you'll handle it Dr gears took a
long sip of his coffee and taking
Bonita's shock silence as confirmation
had a leisurely stroll back to his
office a few moments later the guards
responsible for containing scp-096
arrived on the scene expecting to see
Carnage and find a docile scp-096
crouched over a lifeless body but
instead they found the same truly
bizarre sight that Dr gears had Shrugged
off and Dr Bonita was still doing her
best to process they entered the room
with their weapons drawn but quickly
lowered them scratching their heads in
confusion instead before redoing their
superiors and asking for further
instructions responses from various
Foundation staff who caught a glimpse of
scp-096's bold New Look included oh
would you look at that who's that guy
he's what and in the words of Dr Jack
Bright oh no he's hot
Dr bright also proposed making the new
scp-096 a tick tock account and YouTube
channel seeking modeling representation
for him or selling a novelty calendar
filled with pictures of 096 in various
costumes these would be in his words
quote excellent ways to increase revenue
for the foundation so really you're the
weird ones now for thinking my ideas are
weird Dr Wright was asked to leave
scp-096 alone and stop trying to take
his headshot in the days that followed
the incident with scp-914 the SCP
Foundation was at a loss about what to
do with this new seemingly harmless
version of scp-096 dozens of d-class
were brought in to look at his face and
see if the entity would still enter one
of his range States after a few days of
getting used to his new form but he
never did no screaming no swallowing
people whole nothing more than a polite
if somewhat shy greeting and a courteous
how are you doing today the d-classes
were relieved but confused about being
pulled from their cells just to stare at
some random handsome man Dr clef
suggested dissecting scp-096 to see what
his new body looked like on the inside
this request was denied several
interviews were conducted to evaluate
scp-096's mental and emotional state now
that the anomaly was capable of coherent
speech it was much simpler to evaluate
the Potential Threat Level he might pose
every researcher who spoke with him came
to the same conclusion gone was the
danger of the old
scp-096 he had not just become beautiful
in a classical superficial sense but he
had become beautiful on the inside as
well interviewers reported a warm
friendly demeanor a talent for engaging
in conversation once he was made to feel
comfortable and a sincere interest in
the thoughts opinions and feelings of
those he spoke with there was only one
thing left to do to make sure that
scp-096 had really changed from
something deadly to something almost
resembling an ordinary person a
photograph of
scp-096's face of its original face was
removed from a Secure Vault by a d-class
then the d-class was sent into a room
with scp-096 and instructed to place the
photograph on the table
scp-096 looked down at what had once
been his face and his eyes felled with
tears a soft broken saw left his lips
and he wrapped his arms around himself
hunching over as if in physical pain
outside the room guards prepared to
handle things if 096 began to attack
instead he wiped his tears took a deep
shuddering breath and looked at the
d-class with a somber expression he
picked up the photograph on the table
and tore it in half as he finally
summoned the strength to speed please
kept rid of Thieves that is not who I am
anymore at Dr Bonita's strong insistence
backed up by the conclusions of the
research staff who interviewed scp-096 a
reevaluation of the entity's containment
measure was ordered it seemed cruel and
unnecessary waste of resources to keep
096 trapped in a steel cube in its
current form he would be moved to a
standard humanoid containment cell and
treated as well as other safe class
anomalies provided with books films food
and drink upon request and of course
other Comforts of course the o5 council
insisted on evaluating The Entity before
any of these changes could be approved
dressed in a specially tailored suit
provided by Dr Bonita
scp-096 appeared before the council to
present his case I know that I might not
have the best record at the foundation
I've done a lot of damage over the years
though let's be honest you all aren't
exactly innocent either sorry that was
an attempt of a joke I'm still very new
to talking all I can say is please
consider giving me another chance to
make a real life here to make this place
my home thank you for your time but
scp-096 didn't know is that the o5
council was so flabbergasted by the side
of his new face that they didn't retain
a single word he said they had all given
their official approval before he even
finished his short presentation before
long scp-096 was moved out of his steel
Cube and into a new containment chamber
that resembled the mid-range studio
apartment complete with a bed a
kitchenette a television and a table and
chairs he was provided access to all
major streaming platforms as well as a
large stack of books to help him develop
his grasp of culture and language after
so very long being isolated from Human
Society though he wasn't exactly human
he was determined to act like it word
quickly spread around the foundation's
site and humans and anomalies alike
flock to scp-096's new home to visit him
and see the miraculous transformation
for themselves
scp-999 was the first to come and see
the new and improved 096 chirping
excitedly as it oozed into his room he
pet the Slime gently his face breaking
into a warm Smile as its euphoric effect
wash over him this line became so
excited that meeting this new friend
someone it had known as a source of
sadness and hurt for so long that it
tackled him to the ground and tickled
him for several minutes 096 laughing
uproariously all the while
scp-343 stopped by to give 096 his
Blessing and wish him well in this new
chapter of Life a few days later
scp-507 popped back into the site and
wanted to see the changes for himself he
was thoroughly impressed though
privately confessed to missing 096's
more monstrous form which reminded him
of some of his favorite Cryptids there
was one anomaly that was not thrilled
with the appearance of scp-096 however
scp-056 was Furious upon hearing about
the new beautiful man that everyone just
couldn't shut up about it demanded a
chance to speak to scp-096 and to tell
him that this place isn't big enough for
the both of us I'm the fairest one of
all you sniveling little worm but the
request was denied
scp-056 talked about it for several
weeks meanwhile Dr Bonita was still
intent on getting to know
scp-096 better during previous testing
with scp-978 the desired camera a photo
taken of scp-096 revealed that his
greatest desire was to disappear curious
about the results would be now Dr Bonita
received permission to take another
picture of scp-096 she snapped the photo
while 096 was sitting in a chair in his
new containment chamber looking directly
at the camera when the photo developed
the result was simple everything in the
picture was exactly the same with one
exception Dr Bonito was pictured sitting
next to zero nine six her hand clasped
in his both were smiling soft contented
smiles when she showed him the
photograph he smiled at her and shook
his head it really is an amazing camera
she flushed doctor before you go could I
ask her name Dr Bonita smiled and nodded
it's Isabelle what should I call you SC
096 paused thoughtfully for a moment he
was giving himself a name for the very
first time allowing himself an identity
other than a strange Hollow pale thing
that existed to cry and suffer and hurt
finally he answered her call me David Dr
Dan anxiously paced in his cell it was
the only way he'd been able to occupy
himself for the past six months save for
pouring through files and when he was
lucky being able to oversee another
failed termination attempt he only
stopped pacing when for a brief and
horrible moment he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing
in its big metal cube at this very
moment that horrible creature that he'd
thrown away his life for a feudal shot
at killing perhaps the whole thing had
been a Fool's errand after all he was
formerly a researcher under the employee
of the SCP Foundation secure contain
protect they had truly sadistic beasts
like
scp-106 the nightmarish old man and
scp-352 Baba Yaga in containment cells
and there was no plans to terminate
either of them they weren't the global
occult Coalition for 343's sake why did
Dr Dan even want to terminate
scp-096 in the first place he tried to
explain it to them again and again but
his pleas had fallen on deaf ears in his
mind the impetus for destroying the shy
guy was terrifyingly clear it was a
monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face even a
photograph of it even a tiny collection
of pixels when its rage state was
induced it seemed that nothing would
stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at Breakneck speed and only find it
Zen again once all of them were dead and
if a picture of scp-096 was leaked onto
the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an XK class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic he
preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seated in every
human heart the same drive to Simply
know that led to the creation of the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Doom in
the face of an scp-096 outbreak and if
such a thing happened the foundation
would need to break the Masquerade of
secrecy to have any hope of saving
Humanity in his many feverish nightmares
Dr Dan had seen it all so clearly the
first photographs of scp-096's face
would be leaked online perhaps a few
hundred people across the globe would
look in disparate enough locations that
it would be almost impossible for the
foundation to detect and save all of
them as
scp-096 went on its bloody Rampage of
course as the image proliferated as
images on the internet often do the
purview of 096's violence would only
grow people across the nation would
start to take notice and soon after that
across the world mysterious creature
causing Mass casualties would be the
headline on every news desk because why
would anybody want to talk about
anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
SCP Foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and hysteria would spread
people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when Anything Goes
wrong were refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
Unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere Act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
Fate by Dr Dan's Bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that
scp-096 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp-096 he was simply told to get back
to working on those goggles it was why
he needed to give those naysayers a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph
needed to show up in the home of a
certain Mountaineer it's why all those
people had to die there was no other way
the deaths of the civilians and the
researchers and the mobile task force
members were of course regrettable but
it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though Dr Dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate
scp-096 he was discovering that he
lacked another important factor the
capability they tried incinerating it
exposing it to massive amounts of
radiation exposing it to an insane
degree of kinetic trauma the equivalent
of being hit by an out of control bullet
train they they tested every kind of
experimental off the books Weaponry that
they had access to through various
research projects proton blasts lasers
high intensity energy beams nothing even
when they fried off every scrap of flesh
on the monster's body its unbreakable
skeletons still remained and in what
seemed like no time at all it'd be back
in Action its very existence seemed to
mock him the guard opened his cell door
staring disdainfully at the disgraced
researcher that same guard had slammed
his head against a wall a month earlier
one of his friends had apparently been
killed in the legendary 096 Containment
Breach that set this whole sword thing
in motion up an atom scumbag he sat in
the gruff Surly voice training a handgun
on the doctor he knew wouldn't fight
back they need you in test chamber 6. Dr
Dan allowed himself a small grin
imperceptible to the guard who clearly
hated his gun shots they'd approved his
096 vs 682 cross test marvelous how
marvelous to all the others it would
seem like just one more entry in the
long line of 682 cross tests he thought
it Darkly funny in his eyes the
foundation had no hope of ever killing
scp-682 its defining quality was being
impossible to kill and it didn't present
nearly the threat to the entire world
that 096 posed their futile attempts to
murder the lizard were little more than
a money sink to justify the site's
exorbitant funding but perhaps he could
turn this to his benefit maybe scp-682
would hold the secret to actually
killing off his Nemesis within 30 hours
Dr Dan had his disappointing answer both
anomalies had undeniably done a real
number on each other and Dr Dan did take
a kind of sick Amusement in the mental
trauma that scp-682 had induced in 096
but ultimately it was all for nothing
682 had skin 096 alive and melted off
its flesh with acid but once again that
indestructible skeleton stood firm this
had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident the 27th failed
termination attempt Dr Dan mentally
corrected himself 096's skeleton kept
defeating them even their most Ardent
attempts to penetrate the bones and
destroy the creature within had failed
during a previous attempt they tried to
access the brain by putting a diamond
hard drill into its eye sockets of
course it was the drill that actually
broke much to Dr Dan's seemingly
tireless frustration needless to say in
the debriefing interview with Dr Carver
a researcher who once would have
considered him a colleague he wasn't in
High Spirits if he managed to kill this
thing then he would always be the hero
who made a terrible sacrifice in order
to save many more lives if he didn't
kill 096 he was little more than the
monster who murdered all those innocent
people for nothing though you'd never
hear him say it out loud if it wasn't
for that damnable indestructible
skeleton this monster would be long dead
already if only there was some way to
break the creature's bones that's when
it hit him
SCP-173 the sculpture a site-19 icon
often overlooked because of its more
silent but deadly style but undeniably
one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at site 19
in 1993. one broken neck at a time and
it's one of the few creatures out there
that even the hard to destroy reptile
himself is utterly terrified of perhaps
a monster that practically has a PHD in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the shy guys
vertebrae once his proposal was greenlit
for initial testing Dr Dan arranged for
the shy guy with a bag over his head of
course to be brought into a testing
chamber with the ever stoic
SCP-173 when all the researchers and
guards were safely outside all it took
was a single blink to make all of Dr
Dan's darkest dreams come true in the
nanoseconds his eyes were closed he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the
world a loud fleshy Crunch and a pained
howl from 096 he opened his eyes to an
equally wondrous sight 096 doubled over
at an unnatural angle its spine snapped
between the fourth and fifth vertebrae
spinal fluid leaking down the creature's
flank that freaky little sculpture had
done it it had actually damaged the
Integrity of the Shy Guy's skeleton it
was at that moment that Dr Dan knew he
could kill this thing admittedly there
was a contain payment breach shortly
after that when the bag slipped off of
096's head and it charged through the
nearby steel wall killing multiple
people before being subdued and
recontained but when it comes to
projects involving Dr Dan a mere handful
of innocent people being killed sits
comfortably within the acceptable margin
of error a day later Dr Jan was standing
before a crowded boardroom with agents
researchers and even a few members of
the o5 council in attendance he
explained his findings to them and the
fact that even more importantly they may
have a way to bring The Wretched
existence of 096 to an absolute halt his
plans were approved not long after he
was putting them into motion Dr Dan was
surrounded by researchers and heavily
armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift 096 was
there still bagged off to the side was a
giant tub of hydrofluoric acid connected
to a hose and injector attachment if
this didn't work nothing would everyone
stood back in a safe Zone as 173 was
released to do its thing crunch just
like the previous time 096's spine had
been successfully snapped spinal fluid
dribbled down its skin everyone had
rushed into the chamber when grouped
kept to 173 isolated with their stairs
the other headed by Dr Dan prepared the
acid injector and shoved it into the
breach in 096's spine as the acid was
pumped by the gallon into 096's Bones
the creature let out the most horrifying
whale it kicked and bucked as more acid
was pumped in melting those
indestructible Bones from within the
creature even began to vomit acid as it
panicked melting the bag off of its own
head some panicked and averted their
gaze Dr Dan didn't he stared directly at
the creature's face for the first time
as it melt in front of him with nothing
short of purilation had he won had he
actually won the creature let out a
gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monster's melting Flesh and Bones as it
hollered and shrieked they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them Dr Dan laughed like a madman even
as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling greasy
mess bubbling with chemical life he just
kept laughing even though he knew the
death of 096 meant an equally Swift
death of his own it didn't matter it had
all been for something the world was
saved it was over he'd finally won a lot
of Us wish we could travel the
Multiverse pay a visit to another world
and see all the ways in which it differs
from this Dimension that we call home
maybe there's a decision that you made
that alter the course of your entire
life what college you went to asking
somebody out accepting a job over
pursuing a passion the question of what
if might have kept you wondering what
your life could have looked like if you
picked the other path Shirley would save
you all that wondering and be so much
easier just to go and find out imagine
if you could simply pick a universe
where you chose differently then take a
quick jaunt over there to see how things
turned out for your other self but what
if you couldn't choose never mind
whatever that decision was what if you
couldn't pick where in the infinite
Multiverse you ended up if traveling
from world to world was as random
unpredictable and instinctive as a
sneeze what then one moment you're safe
at home surrounded by everything you
know it might not be perfect but at
least it's familiar the next thing you
know with the blink of your eyes you're
standing in a world that maybe looks
similar but giant bees are the dominant
species instead of humans or the world
is overrun by spiders or everyone is
made out of paint needless to say you'd
be at least a little disoriented at
worst absolutely terrified for your life
that pretty much sums up the experience
of
scp-507 also known as The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper from the outside he
looks to be a mostly normal human man
with blonde hair green eyes nothing all
that remarkable about him of note safe
for him having a somewhat unplaceable
accent despite having a legal name as
cp507 will try to squeeze with little
enjoyment he can out of introducing
himself by a different nickname to
everyone he needs previous favorites
have included Tommy Steve Bruno guy
Houdini and grab knock the Destroyer
we'll stick with Tommy the sole most
intriguing thing about Tommy is that
through a process that happens
completely without troll he can
spontaneously disappear only to reappear
after an unspecified amount of time
later during that time
scp-507 will have been in a completely
different Universe to our own this can
happen at any time of day or night and
usually at the most inconvenient moments
including while Tommy is in the middle
of a conversation trying to sleep or
using the um
facilities he has no control over when
it happens however he'll always arrive
in an alternate universe in the same
geographical spot he was in while in
ours if he moves around in a parallel
world then when he returns he will have
relocated to the corresponding Place
back in this universe and that's when
disaster struck alarms were blaring
declaring to all staff on site that
there had been a Containment Breach in
one of the anomalies holding cells all
hands were on DAC and security teams
were converging dashing through the
corridors this was the second alert
today at first scp-507 had vanished on
one of his unplanned little excursions
but now it seemed that another SCP was
trying to do the same days trying to
reorient himself Tommy rested against a
nearby wall his head was spinning and he
knew it would for a few more seconds he
was in a Cell similar to the one he'd
just been in while in Another Universe
except here back home there was a key to
difference the cell was occupied as soon
as his vision cleared Tommy looked up at
the only other creature in the room with
him it was a tall wiry humanoid shape
completely hairless with pale skin white
eyes and a large gaping jaw turning to
face him Tommy instantly recognized the
creature from a description he'd been
read by a foundation researcher it was
scp-096 uh-oh SpaghettiOs realizing its
face was being observed the shy guy
started screeching first an
uncontrollable whale of distress that
quickly gave way to a guttural
animalistic Roar of anger it covered its
face babbling to itself as Tommy backed
away banging his head against the sealed
wall of 096's cell then the creature
turned towards him and lunged racing
across the room to where scp-507 was
trapped all he could do was close his
eyes tight and think about running away
Tommy could feel a headache brewing in
his skull and caught traces of familiar
flash through his closed eyelids he
gently opened them back up it had
happened again maybe for the first time
ever at a moment when he actually needed
to get away staggering to his feet Tommy
looked around he was in the cell still
rather another version of it in a
different Universe yet again knowing
that he wouldn't be able to predict when
he would next displace he didn't want to
reappear right back where he had started
with scp-096 poise to kill him so
relocating was top priority fortunately
the cell actually had a door in this
universe and that door wasn't locked in
fact none of the doors were locked or
even guarded and the foundation facility
while looking more or less the same was
completely abandoned it almost looked
like it had never even been used
stepping out of the entrance Tommy
trucked his way towards the city he knew
it was a short hike away and by the time
he could feel blisters forming on his
feet he was close enough that it didn't
matter with another few short steps he
was standing among the tall buildings
and surprisingly empty streets one of
the first things that struck Tommy about
this universe was that there were hardly
any people around outside on top of that
the roads were devoid of cars everything
around was so quiet the air was still
and clean when he breathed it in the
sound of footsteps against the pavement
immediately caught Tommy's attention the
first sign of anyone else around other
than him racing towards the noise of
another person Tommy turned a corner and
bummed straight into an old man in a
long coat who had clearly been in a
hurry and quickly revealed he didn't
have the best temperament either watch
where you're going he shouted caught off
guard by the side of another person put
on the streets what the hell are you
playing at sneaking up on me like that
you're trying to get yourself killed out
here oh definitely not Tommy said
climbing back to his feet Hands Held out
apologetically I'm so sorry mister I was
just you got a death wish or something
kid the old man demanded marching past
him no scp-507
protested chasing after the man wait
wait what makes you say that as if you
don't know you scoff look around you
look up at the sky there's a storm about
to hit any second now it's a coming and
if you don't get inside you're a goner
what could be so dangerous about a
thunderstorm Tommy asked the old man
stared back at him with a look of
confusion on his wisen face looking at
Tommy like he had just said something
utterly bizarre what the hell's a
thunderstorm the man asked feeling
equally confused Tommy craned his neck
up towards the sky looming above were
swirling masses of clouds the kind
anyone would expect to be accompanied by
severe winds and the deafening boom of
Thunder but the wind was still and there
was nothing but silence until a choking
gurgling sound came from somewhere
behind Tommy's back he spun around to
see the tall wiry frame of
scp-096 its long fingers gripping
tightly around the old man's throat it
had followed Tommy and he knew that
anyone who saw its face even in a
picture would find themselves chased
down on foot by the creature but he had
no idea the shy guy could travel between
Dimensions he'd foolishly allowed
himself to think he was safe out of the
monster's reach but now it seemed to be
showing him that the opposite was true
it hoisted the helpless old man upwards
by his neck his shoes barely able to
graze the pavement as his legs flailed
eyes rolling back as the shy guy clamped
his throat shut the very second Tommy
turned to run the clouds churned above
and without so much as a warning the
storm hit something wasn't right Tommy
could feel his feet lifting off the
ground immediately panicking as he
thought scp-096 had grabbed him but
looking over his shoulder showed the
creature was still a few feet behind and
starting to gently float up off the
ground too instinctively Tommy's leg
started thrashing around trying to gain
a solid footing instead all his urgent
motions did was cause him to start
spinning uncontrollably as the gravity
storm lifted him higher and higher up
into the air spinning him around as he
was taken further upwards Tommy caught
sight of scp-096 the shy guy was staying
still as if it was still in control of
its body's motion while he was wildly
flipping over himself the tall pale
creature drifted closer to the side of a
nearby building with Tommy being barely
able to reach the top of the street
lights as he was pulled further away
from the safety of having both his feet
on the ground just as he saw scp-096
push itself off the edge of the building
drifting straight through the air
towards him Tommy shut his eyes again
and prayed he displaced again sure
enough a flash of Light Came bursting
out in time with another headache
suddenly he had appeared in the exact
same spot in Another Universe however
here there was no gravity storm in
progress here in fact no such phenomenon
existed the laws of physics were much
more in keeping with those in Tommy's
home our universe of course that would
be more reassuring if he wasn't already
several feet up in the air the second he
arrived Tommy started plummeting back
down to earth screaming as he felt
himself falling keeping his eyes screwed
shut as he dared not look at the ground
he was currently hurtling towards his
plummet was broken by something not
particularly soft whatever it was seemed
to Tower high enough that Tommy only
picked up a few bruises as he hit it but
the fall didn't stop instantly instead
he kept on toppling through whatever he
had landed on it was some kind of mass
piled up almost as tall as a building a
collection of lots of things that were
all brushing past Tommy the more he fell
he hadn't yet stopped for long enough to
recognize the sensations that is until
he landed with a painful thud slowly
opening his eyes back up Tommy could
barely see anything in front of him he
was so deep in the mass that the pile
was blocking out the sunlight with only
a few beams Bleeding Through the gaps
but barely enough to give him a clear
view of where he was Tommy tried to
crawl forward squeezed between the heavy
things around him pushing through
whatever tiny little crevice he could
find as he did the weight of the pile
shifted around him and he was worried
that any moment he would move the wrong
part of it bringing the whole structure
collapsing down on top of him like a
toppled Jenga Tower only big enough to
crush him to death he forced himself not
to think about exactly what the pile was
made of either it was already long past
the point where Tommy recognized what
each thing felt like plus there was the
added stench something or lots of
somethings rotting and producing a
stomach turning odor as it decayed even
when you're not trying to look it can be
hard to mistake the feeling of a hand an
arm cold skin against his the light from
Beyond The Pyramid was getting closer as
he could see was starting to eliminate
more of his surroundings the closer he
crawled to the perimeter sure he could
have very easily used the torch the
foundation let him keep with him but
Tommy wasn't quite ready to see what he
was crawling through yet intentionally
shutting his eyes and opting instead to
follow the faint glow and distant warmth
of the sun breaching the outer side of
the pile Tommy gulped down lung fulls of
air it barely tasted or smelled that
much cleaner than the air within the
mass but at least free clawing himself
out and along the ground he finally
carefully stood up still keeping both
eyes Scrooge shot part of him really
didn't want to take a look around at
this new dimension maybe if he waited
long enough he would displace again and
end up somewhere with less decomposing
but then he remembered scp-096 was still
after him and he had no idea how to
escape it he needed to try and figure
out what he was going to do and the only
way to do that was to look around at
where he was lifting his eyelids the
different sized masses of all shades
shapes and sizes lay before him each one
was coded in one unifying color all of
them slick with the Crimson of blood
against skin Tommy could feel the urge
to throw up quickly shooting up from the
pit of his stomach towards his throat as
he looked at the massive pile of bodies
in front of him it was enormous there
were so many dead people all laying on
top of one another that the pile reached
up as tall as office building in the
pile that he had fallen into and crawled
his way out of wasn't the only one
either as far as the eye could see
everyone was dead feeling a heavy SOB at
the back of his throat Tommy swallowed
it when he heard another sound above the
low buzzing of flies over the human
carcasses someone something else was
crying nearby and the moment he turned
around the familiar figure caught
Tommy's eye even without being the only
other living thing around for Miles the
shy guy still stood out clear as day
it's distress at finding itself in this
horrible Dimension briefly mirrored
Tommy's own until it re-established its
psychic link with its victim and gave
Chase once more
scp-096 started dashing towards scp-507
for a split second he thought about just
letting it catch him what difference
would it make in a place like this but
then the hallucinations of bright colors
and a stinging deep within his skull hit
Tommy and just like that he was gone
again it was not my time in the next
Dimension Tommy arrived in the cold air
and dim light of the street were enough
to give that away but at least he was
away from that last World filled with
discarded and unburied piles of corpses
he thought to himself surely he couldn't
possibly be anywhere worse than that now
the first sight that Tommy was met with
was a huge white LCD screen big enough
to cover the entire side of one of the
skyscrapers facing him emblazoned
against the bright white glow was a
familiar symbol a circle with three
arrows Crossing its outline and pointing
towards its center around that was a
thin frame another Circle this one with
three protruding rectangles around the
circumference in line with the arrow
Tails thick lettered text appeared on
the screen too beneath the emblem boldly
proclaiming that anyone reading it
should submit comply persevere Tommy
blinked in disbelief looking around
there was hardly anyone else around save
for a few people staring at had they
seen him appear or was it just because
he was dressed so differently to them
each of them had on a grimy pair of
overalls sporting more of that same
symbol on the chest and across the back
every wall of every nearby building was
overfilled with posters featuring
matching imagery each one posing
different questions in the same
unforgiving accusatory text against its
clinical white background one poster
read could you be anomalous submit for
testing today another had the following
notice curfew still in effect 10 a.m to
8 am the following morning all citizens
must comply and one more touting that
only through persevering will we
continue to thrive each of them was
signed with the same name and logo to
match the organization that Tommy had
come to put some amount of trust in even
though they weren't always clear with
him but he knew they weren't the bad
guys or at least the version that
existed in his Universe didn't seem to
be that bad they had questionable
methods but they weren't evil weren't
this by order of the SCP Foundation
allowed militaristic voice barked from
behind Tommy get down on your knees with
your hands behind your head you will
surrender any anomalous technology and
declare any memetic effects or Cognito
hazardous abilities before we approach
you Tommy looked over his shoulder met
with the barrels of several automatic
weapons that were now being trained on
him instantly he threw his hands in the
air terrified that this alternate SCP
Foundation might be far more trigger
happy than the version of them he was
used to from the look at the oppressive
text on the huge screen the propaganda
posters and the matching uniforms
Ordinary People seemed forced to wear
this Foundation seemed to be far more
ruthless they had transformed from a
secretive organization into a full-blown
authoritarian regime maybe even in
control of the entire world ruling with
an iron fist on your knees the commander
of the mobile task force shouted again
the aggression in his voice as well as
the several laser pointers from his
men's guns that were hovering over his
chest prompted Tommy to do as he was
told do you have anything to declare
before we approach the MTF leader barked
uh no Tommy stammered before realizing
that was probably an inadvisable answer
ah I mean yes I'm I'm scp-507 but that
number might refer to someone different
here look what I'm saying is this isn't
my Dimension okay I have a condition
that sends me to different universes at
random I can't control it it just
happens please for the love of God don't
shoot better radio into command the team
leader told one of his subordinates tell
them to run that number against the
archives then inform Lord adjudicator
cleft that we may have a Containment
Breach overhearing what they were saying
instantly reminded Tommy that he was
still being chased wait he called to the
elite operatives there's something else
you need to know what's that 507 the
Commander's side lacking the patience
for this there's another anomaly after
me Tommy explained hurdly I don't know
how long it will take to get here just
that when it does it'll kill everyone to
get it me I've heard enough Troopers
take him away the commander grunted two
of the MTF team rushed up to Tommy and
grappled either of his arms not letting
go despite his protests they started
dragging him towards their armored
vehicle looking like Tommy was about to
spend the foreseeable future in the
clutches of one of the worst versions of
the foundation that is until a tall pale
creature stepped out from behind the
transport the mtfs were instantly
frenzied and yells of another anomalous
contact were quickly drowned out by the
noise of gunfire all the while the shy
guy was casually moving between the
amassed troops gripping their heads
twisting them all the way around until a
sickening crunch rang out dropped back
to the ground
scp-507 started to feel another headache
coming on knowing that any second he'd
displace again and end up in another
alternate universe and for the first
time today he was okay with that it was
better for their Chase to go on if it
meant that him and the shy guy didn't
have to spend another minute in this
Universe he's waiting for you in the
dark he sits cross-legged still as a
Placid Lake and patient as a Praying
monk six feet deep in meditation he's
been like this for so long his body oil
slicked with deadly black grease skin
ancient and Haggard eyes black and flat
with the kind of calm you'd only find in
crawling insects and great white sharks
his lipless mouth is stretched across
his Jawbone in an ugly black rectus he
may be an old man but trust us he's got
plenty of New Tricks he'd love to show
you he sat in the loneliest place in the
world the deep dark bowels of an SCP
Foundation containment site surrounded
by a complex Confluence of containment
measures different shapes running
liquids Bright Lights the kind of Steel
so thick a nuclear weapon would only
leave it scuffed all the things that had
a tendency to confuse him because that's
all they ever did the old man laughed to
himself very quietly all the people out
there are so scared of him because of
one immutable fact he isn't trapped here
he's just resting by virtue of his
unique anomalous abilities to pass
through solids at will and resist any
form of physical damage they can dull
out there is no way to really contain
him like all the others all the SCP
Foundation could hope to do was make
leaving inconvenient enough for him to
make his little adventures on the
outside less appealing than just sitting
around doing nothing after all he had
all the time in the world when you
always have a later there's a lot less
pressure to do anything now like all
thinking creatures and Please be aware
that scp-106 The Wretched terrifying old
man is very much a thinking creature he
was subject to a occasional boredom and
when most people are bored they might
play a video game watch a few YouTube
videos or re-watch It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia for the fifth time but for
the old man killing boredom involved
well killing people but not just killing
people of course truth be told for him
killing was really the least
entertaining part of the whole Affair
the screams the begging the desperate
pleas warm tears on shaking cheeks
convulsions of pain cold sweats fear so
intense it gives way to gibbering
Madness the doll Sheen of dead hope in
their eyes when they realize that their
Doom is inevitable and that he their
captor their torturer would decide the
exact moment they slipped into the void
of that that was what he lived for if
you could call what the old man did
living He cracked his neck and licked
his teeth was he salivating all those
thoughts about pain seem to have gotten
worked up he could feel the distant
thumping of his heart old black blood
pumping through the dusty corridors of
his vascular system synapses booming and
sparking with excitement at the thought
of Plumbing new depths of human misery
like a scholar of suffering a pioneer of
pain all those silly Foundation drones
with the audacity to think they're in
control he'd teach them to scream again
meanwhile in the room for the old man's
containment chamber all hell was
breaking loose monitors on the monster's
vitals were all spiking hard and brain
activity peaked just as they always did
before the old man decided to get active
cameras in his containment chamber
showed him Rising steadily to his feet
cracking his joints limbering up his
body started to produce that terrible
corrosive mucus at an accelerated rate
pooling around his feet and unleashing
squalls of noxious fumes as it melted
into the floor years of foundation
testing and they still couldn't find any
material that could withstand that vile
black slaw as the old man began
strolling towards the wall a containment
specialist in the control room grabbed a
nearby phone and sounded the alarm for
the Containment Breach they needed a
mobile task force and every guard on
site mobilized to tackle 106 before he
got into the facility proper and started
causing Havoc they couldn't risk it
escaping either the infamous incident
when the old man escaped for a Halloween
Massacre still haunted the nightmares of
many a staff member he had to be stopped
now a small fighting force was quickly
armed and assembled along with armor and
several high-intensity portable lights
to hopefully slow the monster down in
time for them to grab a d-class and set
up the femur Breaker by the time they
all reached the hall hallway they
intended to use as a choke point for the
escape the old man was already halfway
through the outer layer of Defense
phasing through the wall with that same
terrible manic grin he always had when
he was about to inflict terrible
violence for the sheer fun of it the
guards and task force members trained
their lights and weapons on him all of
them had seen terrible things on the job
the kind of things that would saddle
almost anyone with a lifetime of trauma
but almost nothing compared to the
horror of direct engagement during a 106
Containment Breach that terrible old
coffin Dodger was hell on two legs when
they discovered to their horror that the
lights didn't seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated they fell
back on Plan B that b standing for blast
the living hell out of him with
everything they had the Personnel opened
fire pumping round after round into his
stock form while each gave a loud meaty
splatter the old man didn't even Flinch
when he was close enough all those
months of lethargy gave way to sudden
deadly speed in many ways the old man
was like a crocodile a Fierce and
intelligent Ambush Predator who
conserved his energy wisely he could
seem so deceptively languid that you
could easily mistake him for something
slow and harmless but when you got
within Arm's Reach the sudden quickness
and ferocity would take you off guard
and by then it's already too late within
30 seconds the old man was the only
thing left alive in that hallway all the
guards and task force operatives sent to
slow him down lay dead dripping with his
black mucus there was silence saved for
The Quiet fizzing of the mucus eating
into their clothes and skin the old
man's side how boring he'd killed so
many people now it all started to seem a
little samey how many screams could you
hear before they all just blended into a
single shrill wine you can get sick of
even your favorite meal if you eat it
too often but that didn't matter the old
man had a different order of business
today he happened to be inside an SCP
Foundation containment facility filled
with so many fascinating specimens of
non-human entities that the one they
called
scp-106 simply couldn't wait to torture
he'd only met a small portion of the
ones they had contained here but given
what a fascinating experience his past
attack on his fellow anomalies was he
couldn't wait to meet some more
meanwhile the site's top brass did all
they could to try to mobilize a second
response to the Rogue senior citizen
from Hell currently strolling through
their high security containment facility
could they get in contact with other
mobile task forces deployed in the area
maybe they could get hammer down or
samsara in on this mess before anything
got really out of hand the old man
seemed more intent on something this
time they suspected even the femur
breaker might not work in luring him
back until he claimed whatever he deemed
to be his prize maybe they should
contact the o5 council security guards
were tracking 106's progress through the
facility via their vast networks of
security cameras they warned any
research Administration and janitorial
staff to clear out of his path unless
they felt like being tortured to death
he hadn't dragged anyone into his pocket
Dimension yet so whoever that privilege
was reserved for would probably be
getting a particular sticky experience
they could only speculate as to the
silent BEAST's intentions one guard
noticed something when cross-referencing
106's movements with a map of the
facility they were able to triangulate
where he was heading straight for the
containment chamber of
scp-096 the guard's lips curled into a
slight smile thinking if one of you
freaks can actually kill the other maybe
something positive Will Come Out of This
Disaster the old man was having a stroll
down memory lane the time prior when he
broke out of his cell and decided to
hassle his fellow inmates was certainly
eventful he wound up in the company of
some cantankerous reptile and a Korean
Fox woman an unlikely pair if ever there
was one after finding himself in a room
with them he decided they should have a
little more privacy and dragged them
back into his pocket dimension for
further fun of course with two at once
his attention had been a little split
they spent as much time tussling with
each other as resisting his attempts to
torment them they definitely put him
through his Paces that day and he gave
far better than he got after so many
hours of brutal mutilation there was
barely any of the lizard left despite
its frustrating insistence on quickly
healing from so many of its wounds still
it was good exercise even if the results
had been a little less than satisfying
if he could get another anomaly alone
though he'd be able to take his time and
really Savor the pain he caused of that
sounded Heavenly soon he came upon an
incredibly strange containment chamber
that quickly caught his eye it looked
like a huge metal cube with no way in or
out not even a scene whatever was
trapped in there the old man thought it
must be something that even the fools at
the SCP Foundation really truly wanted
nothing to do with but even more so than
the strange sight it was the sound that
Drew the old man in tempting him like a
siren song it was weeping a soft sobbing
Keen that betrayed a bottomless well of
misery whatever was making that crying
sound had known true despair or whatever
passes for True despair before you've
had a close encounter with the old man
in his pocket Dimension the old man
grinned and thought Oh Sunny I'll give
you something to really cry about he
stepped forward and phased his way into
the metal cube the creature was in the
corner in contrast to that stupid lizard
this monster was pleasingly humanoid
with presumably all the familiar pain
points Splendid the only real difference
was color and proportion it was far
longer and ganglier than the average
human with grayish skin and no hair
anywhere on its body still it was
something the old man could work with
the creature didn't even seem to
register his presence he just sat
crumpled in the corner weeping still
grinning his lunatic grin The Old Man
approached and rested a moist hand on
the creature's shoulder its pale skin
began to fizzle from the intruder's
corrosive touch a pool of vile sludge
began spreading out beneath his feet
until the creature was encompassed too
little by little they sank into the old
man's favorite place out of the world
the pocket Dimension his own personal
Eternal infinite dungeon where the only
laws are pain and Terror for all but the
old man himself little did he know this
time this scores may be a little more
even on that front they both stood in
that terrifying Labyrinth of hallways
and Chambers where the old man had made
countless lives infinitely worse than
any terrible afterlife that could follow
them and still this creature didn't seem
to change its reaction he was almost
irritated by it and what's more this
whole time the creature hadn't even
turned to look at him he'd have to fix
that too the old man with a shocking
strength gripped the monster's shoulder
and whipped him around staring into his
face bearing his black eyes and manic
smile but he couldn't help find what
looked back at him
disconcerting its eyes were blank and
white its face stretched and warped into
a permanent Grimace like Munch's old
painting The Scream and the second the
old man laid eyes on it that's exactly
what it did escaping mouth let out the
most terrible whale the old man had ever
heard in all his years of torturing it
was scream of unknowable sadness and
fear but somehow the old man sensed that
this creature didn't fear Him it feared
itself feared what it was about to do
what the hell had he dragged down here
with him without warning the terrible
whale soon gave way to sudden and
ferocious aggression just like the old
man had dealt out to a group of
foundation guards and mobile task force
agents earlier that same night it was
only out of a mix of pure luck and his
own finely tuned animal Instinct that
the old man was able to dodge the first
strike from the creature's long lith
forelim he couldn't believe it they were
in his special place and this victim of
his had the audacity to fight back well
he'd soon put this monster in its place
as the monster continued roaring and
swiping for him the Old Man simply
walked backwards into a nearby wall and
disappearing into a black stain of
course the monster better known to the
foundation as scp-096 or the shy guy
simply crash through the wall to give
Chase but on the other side just another
wall he disappeared how typically when
something sees the face of the shy guy
he immediately has a kind of intuitive
connection to them he can sense their
presence it's burned into his mind a
homing Beacon an Unstoppable imperative
he knows exactly where they are and how
to get them but nothing about this
situation was typical the shy guy felt
all the murderous rage he normally did
the rest was just static where was the
life he needed to abolish hiding
suddenly the old man emerged behind him
and forced his hand into the Shy Guy's
back his fist melted straight through
flesh and skin causing the creature to
let out another terrible whale but as
could be expected they didn't leave a
scratch on the Shy Guy's indestructible
skeleton the shy guy pulled the 180 and
swung for the old man again but he was
already gone here in the pocket
Dimension the old man had the ultimate
home turf advantage hear space and time
were his playing things in the infinite
twisting Labyrinthian walls of the
pocket Dimension the old man wasn't just
the devil he was God too but it would
take far more than some cheap tricks and
bodily harm to dissuade the shy guy from
his sole purpose in life he began
running through the old man's personal
maze like a crazed lab rat tearing
through wall after wall forever
searching for the monster that trapped
it here it would see the smiling face of
that rotten old man every so often the
flash of black eyes and dirty teeth and
shadows but every time it tried to
strike the Shadows there would be
nothing there and every time he got a
chance the old man would emerge from the
Shadows behind the shy guy to strike
back clawing into his flesh and
Vanishing again before the trapped Beast
could retaliate the nasty old sadist was
now starting to have some fun it was a
reflex test a classic game of
high-stakes whack-a-mole and every time
the creature failed to strike him its
distress only seemed to
this was perfectly fine for the old man
after all he enjoyed a little mental
torment as much as he loved physical
torture and a human would have died or
given in to despair long before now this
Monster's wonderful mix of resilience
and pain made it a great chew toy the
old man kept up this routine baiting and
striking until something unanticipated
happened he appeared waited for the
swing disappeared as it approached then
reappeared behind the shy guy to deliver
another painful strike this time however
it seemed his victim had anticipated his
pattern before he could hit the creature
the shy guy turned quicker than anything
the old man had ever seen and hit him
with such Force he flew through several
walls in his own maze shattering them as
he went he hit the ground stunned by the
fact that the shy guy had actually
landed a hit but he wasn't done the
shrieking monster came bounding after
him before the old man could stand it
struck him again and again and again
pounding his body into the ground which
cracked and crumbled the old man sneered
and sank into a puddle of his mucus on
the ground the old man was gone again
scp-096 screamed in a mix of Rage
Despair and frustration so consumed with
its hunt that it didn't notice the pool
of corrosive mucus was slowly growing it
began to rise bubbling and hissing at
scp-096's feet getting deeper and deeper
and deeper as the walls Rose taller and
taller around it the creature wailed
until a tide of the awful stuff reached
its face and cascaded down its throat
melting all the organs within as the
creature was fully submerged as cp106
manifested atop the wall and looked down
smiling spitefully he thought oh you may
have had me there boy oh but in the end
I always win nothing could survive that
and yet bubble still Rose from the slot
below the old man gritted his rotten
teeth and bawled his fists in quiet
anger moments later back in our
Dimension a portal opened in the ground
of scp-096's containment chamber it
vomited out scp-096's skeleton smothered
in bubbling black goo and
scp-106 096 would probably be fully
regenerated within a couple of hours and
if 682's encounter with him was anything
to go by probably extremely unwilling to
interface with the old man and the old
man himself who couldn't help but feel a
little humiliated by the whole
experience was glad the two of them
would probably never meet again he left
the regenerating 096 and commenced the
Walk of Shame back to his containment
chamber they didn't even need the femur
breaker he just felt like having a sit
down and processing it all nobody else
would ever know what happened in the
pocket Dimension that day and for the
old man's Pride that was probably for
the best but he'd know he'd always know
by the night's end he was sitting in his
containment chamber again for Lauren Lee
wondering God damn it old-timer have you
lost your age a group of well-armed
mobile task force members entered the
containment chamber armed to the teeth
some face the ground droplets of sweat
dripping onto their visors some wore Dr
Dan's Infamous scramble goggles and one
particularly Brave member of personnel
wielded only a bag the room they were
currently standing in was perhaps the
most dangerous place in the world why
because it contained two terrifying
Titans of the anomalous world
scp-682 the infinitely hateful hard to
destroy reptile and scp-096 the shy guy
the ultimate mindless killing machine
and if the very idea idea of having them
in the same place doesn't feel risky
enough the deadly Duo had just spent 27
hours in one of the most brutal brawls
imaginable and incidentally fights like
this are exactly why we're here today we
cover a lot of scps on this channel and
we've seen the way some of the most
dangerous anomalies out there can tear
their way through civilians and train
Foundation MTF operatives with ease but
how do they fare against Monsters
maniacs and reality Benders their own
size with the help of the scp-explained
audience we're going to explore
theoretical fights between some of the
anomalous world's biggest badasses and
who better to get this show on the road
than two of the most iconic and deadly
monsters that haunt the halls of a
foundation containment site near you the
hard to destroy reptile and the shy guy
are household names for anyone familiar
with the SCP Foundation and before we
get into the gruesome results of their
first fight and your theories about how
potential rematch might play out let's
get to know the combat prowess of this
pair of nasty customers what kind of
damage are they capable of taking and
inflicting spoiler alert it's a hell of
a lot in this corner we have scp-682 a
monster whose ability to survive
seemingly anything is only equal by its
terrible attitude towards pretty much
everyone and everything around it though
to be fair you'd probably be a little
grumpy too if the SCP Foundation was
constantly trying to murder you in
different ways rather than just keeping
you contained 682's basic offensive
power set involves impressive strength
speed intelligence and the aid of its
deadly fangs claws and tail however 682
is considerably stronger after it's just
survived and regenerated from a
termination attempt that's because the
true combat assets of 682 is and always
has been its adaptability specifically
if some kind of attack brings 682 into a
state of near death but doesn't finish
the job 682 will generally either
develop a perfect defense or
counter-offensive for that attack or
somehow add a version of the attack to
its own Arsenal this has ranged from
Super pressurized Jets of its own blood
dangerously radioactive banana beams
firing out of its mouth and even an
incapacitating laughter blast gain from
an encounter with the adorable scp-999
it is an absolute Swiss army knife of
dangerous anomalous powers and abilities
and if you need any further proof of
that check out our multiple videos on
all the ludicrous failed attempts to
kill this nightmare lizard and in this
corner we've got
scp-096 the shy guy while 682 is
freakishly adaptable in most situations
scp-096 is pretty much Unstoppable this
long gangly creep will murder anyone who
sees even the tiniest glimpse of its
face with such ferocity that not even a
trace of the body will remain it does
this by entering what many call its rage
State activated by the sudden immense
distress of its face being seen when it
enters this state the SCP Foundation has
is only one prerogative get themselves
and anyone else out of its way because
you will not stop this thing until it's
killed its Target all the SCP Foundation
has ever been able to do is wait until
after the target has been obliterated
and then come in to bag its head when it
enters its docile State almost nothing
else has even successfully slowed it
down while they have been capable of
damaging its flesh the monster skeleton
seems to be utterly indestructible and
its damaged flesh has proven
consistently able to grow back the
monster seems to be immune to everything
from Pain to cold and moves at such a
speed that it's pretty much impossible
to escape for long so when you factor in
an indestructible body immense strength
immense speed and an Unstoppable urge to
kill anyone who sees its face you're
looking at a formidable opponent it's
only natural that the foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests
so what exactly happened when the mobile
task force entered the room after this
first epic battle what do they find
inside the chamber in the grizzly
aftermath
scp-096 lay crumpled in the corner
wheezing scared covered in its own blood
682 was barely recognizable 096 had
reduced it to a quarter of its original
size the rest having been utterly torn
to shreds both had narrowly survived the
encounter but it was an epic battle
neither of them would ever forget though
this was especially true for
scp-096 you see as we alluded to earlier
scp-682 is used to taking a kicking at
this point it hasn't ever truly been
killed but it's been beaten eaten burned
Zapped and smashed within an inch of its
life more times than you can count 096
on the other hand was not used to not
being able to utterly eliminate its prey
while it is impossible to speculate
what's going on inside
scp-096 is mined all evidence points
towards getting a draw in this battle
seriously damaging
scp-096's confidence now every time
Foundation Personnel tries to bring 096
into 682's containment chamber he begins
crying and scratching at his own face
why is he scared of 682 is he humiliated
thinking of the fight he wasn't able to
win or is the very idea of someone
seeing his face and him not being able
to immediately kill them just to
unbearably stressful seeing as the shy
guy's mouth is only good for two things
and neither of them are for talking will
never truly know but either way it's
clear that 096 has no interest in a
rematch but what if that changed what if
096 realized that it was wasting its
potential it managed to get scp-682
three-quarters of the way to death last
time what could stop it from getting
that last quarter sure nothing has ever
killed scp-682 before but there's a
first time for everything right maybe
096 would have a rocky-style training
montage where he rebuilds his confidence
and becomes the underdog he was always
meant to be you'd walk right up to that
big nasty reptile and give him the
rematch of the century what would happen
then now we give the floor to you the
loyal viewers of SCP explained here are
some of your thoughts theories and
opinions on a potential historic rematch
between these two creeps let's get ready
to rumble
Rumble really wanted
to say that oh I really like saying that
Pingu with an ax said if 682's
adaptability is based around his ability
to develop countermeasures to any damage
inflicted or in the case of 173 a
countermeasure to the cause of said
damage I imagine 682 would turn his skin
entirely reflective causing 096 to see
his own face and the feedback loop would
break his mind hmm interesting whether
this would work is all dependent on
whether scp-096 can actually see or if
it is merely capable of psychically
intuiting when someone else sees its
face if the latter is true then this
particular adaptation wouldn't do much
good for scp-682 random user said if
this is after their first cross test and
they were forced to interact again they
wouldn't attempt to fight each other I
feel like they'd form a truce and take
out the researchers on site yeah this
would be one of the worst case scenarios
whether even the SCP Foundation could
handle a simultaneous 682 and 096 breach
without bringing in hammer down is an
open question Ramon vonkin said simple
after the first encounter when 096
stopped attacking 682 682 will grow eyes
that filter out 096's face the next time
organic scramble goggles Dr Dan would be
fuming with jealousy Coop sator said I
really want scp-096 to win so I'm
sending him a blind personal trainer so
he can beat the snot out of scp-682 this
is exactly the kind of help scp-096
needs he's got the rage endurance and
strength with a little help getting his
form and technique in order he'd be an
even more formidable opponent Kyoto Rio
said I'd like to imagine 096 after
playing with 682 for so long would try
to eat 682 in a vain attempt to kill it
only to gain 682's abilities and vice
versa either of these options would be
horrifying
scp-096 with 682's abilities or 682 with
096's abilities would likely be a truly
perfect killing machine that that's
terrifying Autumn said what if they just
shared a nice cold drink while playing
Mario Kart I'm sure 096 would be the
white Shy Guy character in every race
personally we love this idea and we
think 682 would go for Bowser I
personally go for Luigi Ibrahim Timur
said 682 would win eventually it's way
more intelligent adaptive and overall
malicious while 096 acts just on
Instinct this is undeniably a good point
with 682 lacks and sheer savagery it
makes up for in its ruthless calculating
intelligence could this give it the edge
over 096 Monomoy Mukherjee said that
fight would be interesting because both
of them now know how they attack and
what their attacks are nice segue due to
the relatively mindless nature of 096 as
far as we're aware it's probably unable
to learn from experience 682 however
would have the advantage of knowing how
096 operates in the Second Battle Devon
Smith said as much as I'd like to see
how this would play out I imagine 096
can't manage more than other scps have
in the past not to downplay him but he
might need some extra friends to do a
whole lot more damage it's undeniable
that going in with tag team partners
would better 096's chances of taking the
lizard down however due to scp-096's
shyness and tendency to kill everyone
and everything that looks at him he
doesn't have many friends looking to
volunteer Ninetales said 096 will climb
the corner while 682 starts attacking it
eventually it gets confused that 096
isn't fighting back after an hour and
begins to adapt to it and becomes docile
forever okay look while it's unlikely
that this would happen it's certainly
nice to imagine isn't it Adam Britton
said narratively it needs to conclude
with a reason to never try it again so
I'm going to say that 682 will
telepathically project the image of 096
into the site staff or the entire human
psychospace
yikes this is a possibility so
terrifying and honestly plausible that
it's making us regret wanting to see
this rematch all together chaos
Insurgency said I think 682 would just
think for damn's sake just leave me
alone given he's been through more
termination attempts than scp-5031 can
count on its fingers who could blame him
for getting a little frustrated Michael
Porter said I think that 682 and 096
would take each other to court for
aggravated assault against the other
either one of them will get sentenced to
death and will unsurprisingly not die or
the two team up to kill the entire
courtroom and they walk out as a new
serial killing team the real question is
what kind of lores would represent a
pair of murderous anomalous monsters in
court Better Call Saul Ari Workman said
maybe if we try being nice to them for
once we can offer them a cup of tea and
get them both as therapist 682 will talk
all his hate away and then realize his
wrongdoing and become an activist and
096 would become very confident about
his face and become a model there
problem solved hey when people strive
towards self-improvement we're all
winners but we don't know if we can say
the same aim for 682 and 096 even if
this rematch ever did happen perhaps
it'd be just another draw an Unstoppable
Force against an immovable object but
other match-ups may be more clear-cut
what kind of versus battles would you
like to see us cover in the future what
scps would you really love to see duke
it out let us know in the comments and
keep an eye out on the community posts
in order to throw in your anomalous two
cents for our next versus Battle what
does a monster look like to you what
figures Slither and Claw their way into
your nightmares chasing you down endless
halls and stalking you through the dark
until you wake up screaming maybe you
imagine something tall and lean bony
arms reaching for you from a top
impossibly long slender legs its
featureless face showing no mercy maybe
you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers or a serial kill
killer in a hockey mask wielding the
machete maybe it's something more
inhuman a cosmic horror of tentacles and
eyes that can see into your very Soul
you probably don't think of something
with no arms no legs no body at all just
a face What's So Scary About That a face
can't run after you can't grab you by
the ankles and pull you under the bed a
face can only look it may be unsettling
to behold it might send a chilled on
your spine but the worse it can do is
make you a little uncomfortable and if
you can't stand it any longer you could
always just close your eyes but walk
away and be done with it right if that's
what you think if you don't believe in
monsters that can hurt you without
lifting a finger then you're the type to
fall victim to a very special very
intelligent mask in the hollowed Hall of
the SCP Foundation there is a
containment cell outfitted with a
hermetically sealed glass case
surrounded by steel iron and Lead there
are guards posted outside along with a
trained psychologist if you are ever
Brave and foolish enough to enter that
room you'll see a simple white porcelain
comedy mask with a peculiar black
substance leaking from its eyes and
mouth whatever this slime touches
surfaces begin to corrode to rot away
into puddles of black liquid you might
notice the same liquid trickling slowly
down the walls of the room corrupting
everything in its path as unsettling of
a sight as it is if you approach The
Mask to take a closer look you will find
yourself overcome by an intense nearly
irresistible urge to pick it up and put
it on to wear it to let it consume you
from the inside out
puppet your body while your brain simply
turns off like an extinguished flame
you'll simply be gone then who knows
what the mask will do it won't be your
concern anymore that's for sure but
thankfully you haven't gone into the
room with the porcelain mask you haven't
let It cast its spell on you not yet at
least it's waiting for you there in the
room with black slime oozing down its
walls and it will wait patiently for as
long as it needs to after all what's a
mask without a face to wear it
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask sat in its containment cell
immobile as always it didn't really have
much of a choice in the matter the
foundation had chosen selfishly to
revoke its host privileges once upon a
time they offered it bodies to choose
from manic dummies and wooden dolls that
could Adorn and pilot they didn't last
as long as an organic living host of
course but it was something it was a
taste of Freedom this Dreadful new
situation was almost enough to make the
mask want to change its surroundings
this Dreadful new situation was almost
enough to make the mask want to change
its expression from Comedy to tragedy
but it was determined to still find
something to laugh about even without a
body trapped in this infernal box there
had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment human Minds were
fragile things the mask had learned this
over the infinite years of its life if
one could call it a life apply the right
kind of pressure to the right weak
points whisper an enticing word or two
find the right emotional wound to
sprinkle a pinch of salt into and humans
would Buckle completely and almost no
time at all it had tried all sorts of
methods since being confined to this
boring little box sometimes it would
charm someone pour honeyed flattery into
their heads until the person felt like
the mask was a dear friend a confidant
one suitable trust had been built up the
mask could persuade the person to bring
it a host or perhaps even offer up
themselves in sacrifice if flattery
didn't work there were other potent
approaches to take for a being without
ears the mask was a good listener it
picked up on things that no human ever
could the darkest Secrets buried in a
person's mind if it got wind of
something especially juicy and ruinous
it could leverage that threatened to
expose an affair a crime or perhaps
something even worse something
unspeakable if praise failed and so did
blackmail their there was always good
old Supernatural intimidation all the
mask needed was for someone to be left
alone with it for a long enough period
of time then its invisible tendrils
could snake out into their defenseless
mind weaving and poking around leaving a
lingering sense of cold dread of
incomprehensible Whispers in Long dead
tongues what a delight containment had
been in the early days when the
foundation had not yet figured out the
mask's true capabilities when they would
leave security personnel with weak wills
and minimal training standing guard in
the mask's field of influence for hours
at a time as the entity played with
their thoughts and chipped away at their
free will thanks to the helpers it had
been able to mold out of those hapless
victims they had been there to break
open its case and carry it to free
freedom but every time the other guards
thwarted the attempts shooting its
helpers and rendering them utterly
useless then the foundation increased
its security something about the
unacceptably high homicide rates among
staff assigned to a
cp035 how utterly boring how truly
pathetic still The Mask had found ways
to occupy itself even without any more
play things it had grown stronger with
its boredom stretching its influence
Beyond Organic beings and into the very
room itself it's evil enriching and
deepening like a fine wine in the depths
of a cold cellar over the months the
walls of scp-035's containment cell had
begun to secrete the same black slimy
substance that would pour from the
mask's eyes and mouth the liquid dripped
Down the Walls in deliberate formations
patterns that became increasing easy to
recognize Praises in Italian Latin
ancient Greek all detailing ritual
sacrifices and mutilations The Mask took
time to describe the sacrificial victims
in great detail borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members that
it knew would read the translations the
walls were slick with blood and
harrowing imagery and the glass case
around the mask was growing more and
more Fragile by the day anyone within 10
meters of the Mask could feel this
strength too they would leave the area
complaining of unintelligible Whispers
of loud cruel laughter and a lingering
sense of nearly insurmountable despair
it was as if they knew on some level
that no one was truly safe eventually
The Mask would find a way to come for
them all the glass was weakening and
soon the mere thought of us Cape would
make it shatter into pieces then perhaps
The Mask could finally get its deepest
desire
Revenge it wanted nothing more than to
try to make the foundation pay for
imprisoning it for taking away its host
privileges for trying harder and harder
to contain the kind of power that should
have had them falling to their knees in
worship the mask seethed with hatred day
in and day out it had seen the crumbling
of the Roman Empire the beheading of
Kings the decimation of armies it was
not going to be captured by a bunch of
rats in lab coats without dire
consequences befalling them maybe it
couldn't move from its prison cell at
the moment but it also knew that it was
surrounded on all sides by dangerous
beasts capable of reducing the sight and
all who had dared to pose the mask to a
pile of smoldering Rubble if it could
only find its way onto one of their
faces it would show them all just what
it was capable of as the piercing sound
of an alarm echoed down the hall the
sound of Screams and Chaos following
shortly after the mask's frowning face
curved into a broad menacing
smile what was it that had escaped the
lizard perhaps the giant grinning man
whatever it was it seemed that the
action was heading right towards zero
three five's containment cell perhaps
today was the day finally the SCP
Foundation would fall outside the mask
cell security officer Harper was running
for dear life those more rational mind
knew he was living on seconds not even
minutes of borrowed time his animal
brain kept his legs pumping desperately
trying to avoid the screaming howling
Predator Hot on his heels Harper looked
over his shoulder and screamed as a long
white arm reached for him
scp-096 the shy guy it's tooth line jaw
hanging low and foaming with spittle
that face that terrible terrible face an
absolute death sentence to all who saw
it he'd seen what he thought was a crack
in the otherwise perfect seal of 096's
containment chamber but it could have
just as easily been a trick of the light
not even thinking he stepped forward and
looked at the vulnerability in the
chamber all it took was one misplaced
ray of light and he made out the vague
shape of a face in the darkness that's
when the Weeping started Harper knew in
that moment his life was over the
correct thing to do would have been to
order everyone else in the room to close
their eyes while he stood there and
accepted his fate minimizing the risk of
spreading the damage further but humans
rarely have perfect reasoning even less
so when facing mortality back in the
present the shy guy made a perfect lunge
grabbing Harper and its iron clutches
and barreling through the adjoining wall
the nearby guards scattered terrified
keeping their eyes on the floor they
might get a slap on the wrist for
temporarily abandoning their posts but
they weren't going to die guarding some
stupid evil mask speaking of the
possessive mask was surprised to feel
two new presences enter its chamber
through the now destroyed wall these two
presences soon became just one as
scp-096 quickly and totally annihilated
security officer Harper leaving nothing
left the mask couldn't see per se seeing
as it had no actual sensory organs but
it felt around this new guest with its
many psychic tendrils taking in this
strange totality the creature was
powerful no doubt about that and it
elicit fear from those fools at the SCP
Foundation but the mask noticed its
brain waves were extraordinarily muted
humans to The Masks vast and malicious
Consciousness weren't the sharpest
knives in the drawer but compared to
this thing's mine they were a pile of
tempered katanas it barely thought it
all the mask would have to dig deeper to
find anything it could use meanwhile
scp-096 finally began to calm down the
one who had seen it had been annihilated
bubbling rage was slowly siphoned out
and replaced by the standard low but
constant home of anxiety and despair it
would wait until its head was bagged and
it was dragged back to the dark same old
same old all the way to the end of time
that's when it felt something else it
started as a faint Buzz an
unintelligible whisper and it was almost
like a door opened in the back of its
head something stepped in and took a
seat
and you hear me stranger
luck
I want to speak to you
something about the voice frightened and
comforted as cp096 at the same time it
spoke with a greater degree of sympathy
when the creature had heard in a long
time and yet something about the way it
spoke implied evil and its intent
I know what you fear
wouldn't it be nice if they could ever
look into him
if you could cover that face of yours
I can help you
through his foot me on little by little
096 felt more of these strange thoughts
filling up the emptiness in its head
replacing the few little thoughts the
creature itself had it felt itself
lifting its hands from the ground
lifting them and reaching towards
something a glass box the glass
shattered and those long white fingers
reached for something within a mask just
like the voice had said a mask to stop
people from looking at its face
yes
yes
[Music]
scp-096 lifted The Mask to its face
feeling black liquid that burned its
skin dripping from the porcelain and put
it on and in that moment everything
changed the Shy Guy's body began to
seize up rattling as the mask Unleashed
a web of psychic tendrils through its
body mapping out across every inch like
a new nervous system taking control the
possessive mask had never experienced a
host like this before that incredible
perfect mix of physical durability and a
mind so insubstantial that it was easy
to sublimate
for the first time the shy guy now under
the full control of the possessive mask
stood at full height on its hind legs
his spine and shoulders clicking into
place for its new stance The Mask
cracked its neck getting used to the new
dimensions of its physicality its
indestructible bones its long grasping
limbs its skin burning and fizzling with
the gooey black secretions but growing
back just as quickly the foundation had
every reason to fear it now a group of
security Personnel had gathered in the
Ragged hole where the chamber's north
wall used to be some were wielding light
Firearms the guard at the front was
carrying an opaque black bag The Mask
laughed with its new body and turned to
the crowd the second they saw it on
096's body their faces fell for a moment
their bodies went slack with Terror this
situation was unprecedented what course
of action could they possibly take at a
time like this and looked at the bag
held by the leader of the security force
and projected a single thought into his
mind
before any of the guards even had a
chance to open fire The Mask lunged
forwards using the long terrible arms of
the shy guy to tear through the guards
they were dead in seconds their bodies
strewn about the hallway the mask's
porcelain was twisted into a wide
sadistic grin it could tell that it was
about to have some real fun around here
and once it slaughtered everyone here it
could finally stretch its legs out in
the open again true freedom to spread
misery fear and pain everywhere it went
there were just a few hundred members of
foundation Personnel it needed to turn
into corpses first more Containment
Breach alarms sounded around the site as
the mask began its Rampage running
through the hallways and tearing apart
any unfortunate Foundation personality
could get 096's Hands-On guards
researchers administrative staff and
even one extremely unlucky janitor in
hallway C6 it was having the time of its
long and terrible life and much to its
Glee it seemed that this new host's body
was still holding up it was perfect
symbiosis a twisted brilliant mind and a
body that could forever support it there
would be no stopping it a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around
the site soon realized on their own
terms 096 was indestructible but it was
dumb as a brick and had an easily
exploitable weakness get the bag on its
head and you're home free this new
composite creature was a different story
he could think tactically avoiding
head-on confrontations in favor of sneak
attacks and the monster had as much
psychic combat potential as physical
guards roving the building in teams
heavily armed with anti-memetic
protective gear still reported feeling
immense feelings of psychological dread
over calms that was the greatest sign
that the mask would come bursting
through the wall moments later and tear
them to shreds the site director put out
an urgent call for all nearby mobile
task forces to intercept and help them
take care of the unfortunate situation
thankfully a Detachment of MTF 8-10 also
known as see no evil was operating on a
case in close proximity given their
specialization and anomalies within the
medic visual property many on the team
had dealt with 096 breaches before that
at least gave them experience in half of
this situation and one operative among
them Sergeant henrique Ramirez would be
the one to bring this nightmare to an
end but it would cost him his life in
the process the mask was still using its
new indestructible body to wreak havoc
on the containment site once it had
taken out the primary contingents of
guards it was free to have its fun with
the rest stalking defenseless
researchers through the Halls making
sure to induce maximum Terror before
finally striking the killing blow every
single one of them died with a head full
of demonic Whispers it told them that
the mask's Eternal Dominion now it had
found the perfect host nothing on Earth
would stop it humans would be mere ants
under its feet eight a ten touched down
and entered the building Ramirez was
Point man leading the others into the
bowels of the blood-drenched containment
site they'd been briefed on what they
were heading in for 096 and 035 had
reached symbiosis and were displaying
unprecedented anomalous effects enter
with Extreme Caution they're beyond
dangerous even more so together than
alone ideally Ramirez would have wanted
to go in with a comprehensive plan but
lives were on the line here they needed
to leap off the cliff and build their
wings on the way down it was only when
finally encountered the monster that
they realized just how outmatched they
were despite their best efforts the
combined speed intelligence and ferocity
of the mask's new form allowed it to
make short work of ADA 10 only Ramirez
was left heavily injured even if a
miracle happened we knew he wasn't
getting out of here alive The Mask
grabbed him with one of 096's Claws and
lifted him up it would take its time
with this one make him suffer watch him
squirm destroy his mind Ramirez felt the
mask's psychic tendrils penetrate the
membrane of his mind those Whispers
those terrible Whispers reciting all his
worst fears with terrible Glee his gun
was out of ammo his knife was broken all
he had left on him was a pocket mirror
and that was his Eureka moment it was a
long shot but it was also his only shot
he reached out and grabbed the bottom of
the Mask pulling for dear life his other
hand shot into his pocket and grabbed
the mirror opening its lid with a Deft
flick of his thumb it was too fast for
the mass to even register what was going
on Ramirez forced his eyes shut and
lifted up the mirror the mask saw its
own reflection in the glass as the
bottom of its face came loose revealing
the reflection of the face underneath
the mask squeezed killing Ramirez but it
was already too late it had finally seen
the face of its host and that would cost
it dearly The Mask felt a sudden and
tremendous pushback to its psychic
forces a blind Despair and then rage
that choked out everything
scp-096 began to sob and howl somehow
the mask was no longer in control
despite its psychic protests the 096
reached up and tore the terrible mask
from its face tossing it against the
wall with such force that it was
embedded in the brickwork its last
thoughts as other mobile task force
operators descended on the area to bag
096 and return it to its containment
chamber were
what the hell just happened and the next
thought that crossed the mind of the
site director was request site transfer
for 035 as soon as possible don't want a
rebate of this incident anytime soon
well hello there SCP fans let's get this
out of the way first you've seen the
title and thumbnail and you're probably
wondering wait is siren had an SCP and
the answer is no siren head is not an
SCP it's a freaky internet monster
created by renowned Canadian horror
artist Trevor Henderson your next
question is probably what's with this
crazy looking server Bank behind me
allow me to introduce you to the
anomatron 6000 the latest advancement of
supercomputing owned and operated
exclusively by the SCP Foundation it's
capable of a whole bunch of interesting
features calculating ideal containment
methods running state-of-the-art
Foundation web caller software making
and editing fun SCP YouTube videos but
the most interesting feature that the
animatron has to offer is running hyper
Advanced simulations regarding all
things anomalous with data fed into it
by thousands of real-life experiments
conducted by the SCP Foundation it's
going to save countless dollars and
lives for foundation researchers but way
more importantly it's going to let us
explore all kinds of weird and wacky
what-if scenarios that would never
happen organically could scp-343 beat
Goku or Superman who's a deadly or
Supernatural killer
scp-106 or Freddy Krueger would the
world simply explode from adorableness
if scp-999 and baby Yoda ever cross
those multiversal barriers and met we
can explore all of these questions along
with any others you may have down in the
comments seriously comment it we dare
you but to get things started we figured
we'd make the animatron pit the
foundation nation's lankiest nightmare
monster
scp-096 against the internet's Trevor
Henderson's siren head sorry Slenderman
you're just not cool anymore so without
further Ado let's kick the animatron
into gear and see how this wild battle
plays out it's time for scp-096 versus
siren head Ricky and Elliott a pair of
aspiring travel YouTubers from
California were taking a vacation to the
Pacific Northwest to spend some time in
the area's beautiful Lush forests
however while the duo were both big fans
of travel for its own sake they weren't
just here for the trees and fresh air
you see despite their jet-setting
lifestyle Ricky and Elliot subscribers
and Views hadn't exactly been phenomenal
lately turns out hiking Vlogs and GoPro
footage of the two of them jumping into
absurdly blue water and Bali weren't
exactly that interesting to people who
weren't actually there but Ricky had
formulated an ingenious plan to pull the
two of them out of obscurity they would
hunt down and film real footage of the
legendary siren head a supernatural
monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards there were plenty of
fakers out there on YouTube but if the
two of them could get real footage of
siren head and also preferably survived
the experience they'd be framing their
golden play buttons in no time but they
were already encountering certain issues
for starters the two Californians had
severely underestimated just how cold it
was in the Pacific Northwest and as such
were already shivering from bone deep
cold the second issue was food while the
two of them had thought ahead and
brought a selection of tasty protein
bars they'd also gotten hungry during
the early hours of their walk and eaten
all of them leaving them feeling
severely out of luck by the time dinner
rolled around and the third and perhaps
most problematic issue of all was the
fact that Ricky and Elliot didn't
exactly have a great sense of direction
during all of their previous trips
they'd been on guided tours with local
experts in this students wanting to take
all the siren head glory and Cloud for
themselves they decided to come in alone
with the incredibly janky Google Maps
app to guide them as such as the Knight
was creeping in the two aspiring YouTube
celebrities had no idea where they were
needless to say it wasn't exactly an
ideal situation and to make matters
worse Ricky and Elliot had been
experiencing some strange feelings for
the last couple of hours when they'd
gotten particularly deep into the forest
that dread-inducing sensation of being
watched by something lurking just out of
sight a gaze with some unknowable and
Darkly malicious intent boiling behind
it these two poor saps had no idea what
was in store for them tonight and
wouldn't you know it the one watching
them right now wouldn't even be the only
monster after them after an expectable
amount of bumbling and buffoonery Ricky
and Elliot managed to gather up enough
Tinder to make a semi-respectable
campfire they could sleep out here
tonight then set off in search of siren
head or civilization whichever came
first in the daylight the next day the
duo did what they could to remain
chipper in spite of the ominous
circumstances sure they were trapped in
the depths of the woods alone but think
of the amazing Vlog footage they'd get
they'd be like the next Blair Witch crew
except they'd live hopefully but as the
duo sat next to their campfire they felt
that ominous sensation again the hairs
on the back of their neck started
standing up they felt Shivers that
didn't just come from the cold more and
more they started to feel certain that
something in this forest was watching
them something ancient and powerful and
evil that's when they heard The Telltale
crackle of radio static and their
skeletons almost jumped out of their
skin could it be him the patron saints
have gone missing without a trace of
creeping dread of bad things coming
siren head himself both men fell
all they could hear was the crackling of
their own fire had the sound before just
been an illusion a product of a pair of
paranoid mines also predisposed to sense
siren-headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees they'd been reading about a
higher rate of disappearances in this
area along with a number of frightening
sightings of tall thin beings and radio
static that seemed perfectly consistent
with siren head activity that's why
they'd come here in the first place but
had they come here to their deaths the
two needed to distract themselves or
they'd go mad from the paranoia they
decided to share a few fun little
anecdotes of the travels they'd had
before meeting one another showing the
photos they'd saved on their smartphones
Ricky had been to Hawaii Tahiti Bora
Bora Fiji Saint Lucia and the Maldives
clearly he liked his vacations warm and
Sandy Elliot on the other hand tended to
like his trips to be a little more
adventurous he'd seen volcanoes
waterfalls deep and treacherous cave
systems and of course a little guided
mountaineering one photo that Elliot
showed Ricky was particularly
breathtaking he was standing in the
foreground of a snowy landscape with an
incredible mountain range behind him
when Ricky asked Elliot where exactly
he'd taken this picture strangely enough
he drew a complete blank maybe somewhere
in Canada or Siberia or something like
that but it was a hell of a trip
whatever the case he remembered having a
great time it was such a tiny detail but
when looking at the photo Ricky couldn't
help but notice something in the
background a speck of white sure not
exactly newsworthy in the snowy mountain
range but this wasn't snow it was a
speck of white that seemed to be a
slightly different shade than the rest
of the mountain strange perhaps it was
just some tiny particles stuck on the
lens whenever the photo was taken the
two continued to chat and warm their
hands against the fire having no idea of
the horror they just awoken in doing so
over a hundred miles away way at an SCP
Foundation containment site researchers
and guards walked around the perimeter
of a huge airtight metal cube rating off
Diagnostics and audio recordings for
reasons that should be obvious to
everyone who's a fan of this channel
there were no camera feeds coming from
the inside of the great metal cube only
a faint whimpering sound like a sad
wounded animal then the clanking of
pacing feet moving back and forth over
the metal dragging four more Knuckles it
turned every head in the room when the
crying started to get louder soon it
wasn't just quiet weeping it was a
series of horrendous slobbering sobs
whales of pure pain and despair someone
in the room screamed close your eyes and
hit the deck
what had happened they learned well
enough from the infamous incident
096-1-8 Containment Breach that there
was no way of stopping this thing until
it run its course the best they could do
was minimize their own fatalities in the
process everyone in the room did as they
were told hitting the ground closing
their eyes and covering them with their
hands just to be safe that's when the
solid steel of the cube was torn open
like crepe paper from the howling raging
scp-096 Broke Free Galloping on all
fours through the nearest wall
shattering it and spraying debris
everywhere as mobile task forces were
dispatched to track the rampaging
Abomination and try their best to clear
the path ahead as it sought out its
Target one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room woe but
tired of poor fools who saw that
Monster's face back in the deep dark
forests of the Pacific Northwest the
presence of some unnerving force was
becoming far harder to deny for Ricky
and Elliot they heard the sounds of
garbled voices out in the woods the
squeals and crackles of radio static
they saw shapes moving amongst the trees
tall and thin like long spindly limbs
while neither wanted to voice Their Fear
they were both thinking similar things
if there really was a monster out here
why hadn't it killed them it had all the
Time in the World to do it but that was
just it wasn't it it had all the time in
the world so why rush it had every
Advantage it could take its time and do
this exactly how it wanted to Rick and
Elliott had made themselves the perfect
prey and as they saw a huge lith figure
suddenly separated cell from the trees
they began to wonder if it was really
worth it to risk both of their lives for
YouTube Cloud either way it was now
probably too late for regrets Ricky and
Elliot's Jaws fell in horror as the
monster emerged from the darkness before
them they recognized the awful modeled
skin stretched over the monster's
40-foot frame they saw the grasping
hands and up above the nightmarish
faceless head split into a pair of
sirens pointing in different directions
each one filled with gnashing teeth and
slithering tongues it was even more
terrifying than they could possibly have
imagined siren head speakers crackled
into life in his Stout
Ricky and Elliot stumbled backwards as
siren had Advanced its speakers still
bleeding hateful static neither could
move or speak only watch as its long
gnarled fingers reach from the dark to
grasp them there was a terrible pained
whale in the woods after that but it
wasn't coming from Ricky Elliot or siren
head it was distant at first but soon
became louder and louder as the Force's
point of origin came barreling towards
them even siren head couldn't help but
turn to see
scp-096 a flash of terrible white Fury
come charging towards them in the dark
knocking down all the trees in its path
leaves and pine needles scattered trunks
exploded into splinters nothing would
stop the shy guy from claiming its prey
nothing would stop it from destroying
Ricky and now as it approached Elliot
made the Fatal mistake of looking at its
face too 096 lunge ready to go in for
the kill when siren head's hands closed
around the shy guy slender torch
in one fluid motion with surprising
strength for its scrawny build it hurled
the shy guy into the distance smashing
another several trees in its path the
words
hissed out of its speakers but 096 was
only down for mere moments it sprung
back up on its hind and four legs and
started Galloping towards Ricky and
Elliot again who were still frozen in
place this time just before the Shy
Guy's terrible claws could close around
the two hapless wannabe YouTubers down
came siren heads clenched fist pounding
096's head into the dirt overhead mobile
task force helicopter circled wearing
their scramble goggles and trying to get
a visual on the situation unfolding
below they could hardly believe what
they were seeing down there with some
other unclassified anomaly managing to
intercept 096 in its rage state only a
handful of anomalies on record have ever
been shown of being capable of such a
feat it seemed that they were dealing
with something serious here down below
the battle continued siren head had a
unique advantage over most other
combatants facing
scp-096 it was an extra dimensional
being with no eyes merely an innate
psychic awareness of its victims around
it not unlike how scp-096 detect people
seeing its face in photographs or videos
without need for any kind of direct
contact as such it was impossible for
siren head to see the shy guy's face and
thus impossible for the shy guy to ever
actually direct its aggression against
it whether or not 096 would kill steel
siren heads intended prey was another
matter entirely in the night's first
minor miracle Ricky and Elliot
remembered that they've been born with
working legs and decided that right now
would be an excellent time to use them
they turned and began to run while siren
had continued beating the shy guy into
the dirt sprinting with all their might
however the growing distance between
them only aggravated the shy guy further
it sprang out from the dirt with
unstoppable force and broke away from
siren head's grip the shy guy never
wasted time ever it always made a
beeline for its intended victim with one
directive in mind total Annihilation
tonight is no
Ricky and Elliot screamed as they heard
its pounding Gallop on the ground behind
them closer closer closer than suddenly
defying all spatial reasoning siren had
emerged out from the darkness between
Ricky Elliott and 096 being 40 feet tall
siren had dwarfed even the shy guy it
lunged and grabbed the Wailing white
monstrosity holding it as one would a
particularly vicious cat and trying to
keep it in place siren had wanted to
crush the monster's bones and carry on
stalking its feeble human prey who were
currently in the process of getting away
but somehow that was impossible it was
almost like the monster had an
indestructible skeleton up above the
mobile task forces continued observing
this Clash of the Titans from their two
helicopters seeing how siren head was
somehow doing a serviceable job of
subduing the shy guy one of the task
force members joked maybe we should hire
this guy another chimed in I don't think
we have any ballistic vests in his size
the laughter soon turned to screams when
siren had World zero nine six is
flailing body up at one of the
helicopters with Incredible Force
knocking it out of the sky it greened
down to the ground a ball of fear and
violence before exploding anyone who
survived the initial blast was unlucky
enough to have seen the shy guy's face
their screams rang out briefly before
being abruptly silenced by the monster
helicopter Alpha had no survivors
meanwhile Ricky and Elliot had kept
running until their lungs burned and
their muscles pumped thumbtacks seeing
that the chaos was so far behind them
now they took a moment to stop and
breathe recomposing themselves in the
second minor miracle of the night it
looked like the two of them had actually
survived this ordeal those two horrific
monsters had canceled each other out but
Ricky and Elliot were about to learn a
harsh lesson they really weren't that
lucky the last thing the two of them
ever saw was siren head emerging from
the darkness once more the last thing
they ever felt was the monster's
terrible gnarled fingers curling around
their bodies too fast for them to escape
and the last thing they ever heard was
each other's screams followed by a
sickeningly meaty crunch elsewhere in
the forest scp-096's whales died down to
its usual mudlin Saab the rage state had
ended all of its targets had been
destroyed it just hadn't been the one to
do all the destroying per se not long
after that helicopter Bravo descended
safely and the remaining MTF members
closed around the blubbering Beast
someone black bagged it and everyone
breathed to sigh of relief knowing that
was at least one monster taken care of
tonight what about the other one the MTF
Lieutenant asked the team's Commander
shook his head and said ah let's worry
about that freak later and get 096 back
to containment this place gives me the
creeps it happened in 1981. in a small
rural Village in West Germany secret
guys nine years old ran across the
bitter snow tears freezing to his cheeks
it was Christmas Day and not long ago
he'd been so happy he he was celebrating
with his family his mother his father
and his young sister the Sinners of his
Universe when that monster had attacked
and destroyed everything he'd ever known
the white Terror the destroyer of
Christmas cheer the Yule man
scp-4666 though of course young
siegfleet had no idea in hindsight's
siegfleet's parents had been noticing
strange things in the lead-up to
Christmas Day unfamiliar bumps and
knocks strange smells coming from the
attic the occasional tall dark
silhouette on the horizon outside their
isolated old farmhouse but in all the
hustle and bustle of the Season nobody
really paid the proper attention to all
the signs of an incoming hoist knocked
event every Eerie feeling was just
written off as stress or overactive
imaginations none of the guy's family
knew about the true danger they were
facing until they woke up to see the
Yule man standing over them sharpening a
rusty blade and staring at them with
hungry sadistic eyes Merry Christmas the
creature rasped and chuckled Siegfried
was lucky to escape alive but of course
he would never see his family again he'd
be picked up a day or so later
traumatized catatonic and almost frozen
to death when he was finally able to
speak again he spoke of a monster having
killed his family when the police
investigated his home and found the
remains they deemed it to be the work of
an all too human serial killer and poor
secret guys was entered into the Foster
system years of work with psychiatric
professionals trying to convince Jung SI
flee that the monster he claimed to see
the unnaturally tall gnarled bony freak
with those shimmering black eyes was
merely a product of his trauma but he
knew the truth he always knew what he
encountered that day the thing that took
his family was nothing less than a true
monster and at nine years old Siegfried
made a vow he would one day kill the
monster no matter what it took when
secret was finally adopted and returned
to school he did everything he could to
apply himself academically he had no
interest in friends or romantic
relationships even as he grew into his
teenage years the only thing that Drew
his interest in addition to the
Perfection of his academic life was his
own private Research into the
supernatural he became an expert in all
things occultic and anomalous sightings
of ghosts Phantoms aliens and monsters
he wanted to know it all no needed to
know it all he would arm himself with
knowledge wanting to know everything he
could in advance of the confrontation
that would be his final Destiny he also
began obsessively researching attacks
similar to the ones that killed his
family and found an eerie pattern seen
to unfold all over the Northern
Hemisphere during the 12 Days of
Christmas entire families would be found
dead in their homes mutilated
horrifically often with children having
gone completely missing they happen far
enough apart in terms of time and space
that no connection was drawn between the
events all just random attacks according
to the police and media weren't the
connections obvious he didn't understand
it it was almost like there was some
kind of sweeping cover-up obscuring the
true culprit behind all these killings
the same Beast that destroyed his life
as Siegfried now known to most as Dr
guys ascended through his time at
University he became one of Germany's
foremost Scholars on the occult with
several published papers and books that
Drew fascination of fellow experts and
laymen alike but most importantly of all
siegfried's work got the attention of
the SCP Foundation they reached out to
the ambitious rising star of the
Paranormal world and offered him a
research position Dr guys was elated and
said that he would happily take the role
if they answered one question for him
did they know anything about a horrific
humanoid monster that attacked families
across the Northern Hemisphere around
Christmas time this was the moment when
Dr C played guys after Decades of
searching finally came to know about
scp-4666 he had access to all the SCP
foundation's information on the monster
putting him several steps closer to what
had always been his ultimate goal
killing that God forsaken thing but this
would be easier said than done after all
if the Yule man was easy to track the
foundation would have captured and
contained him long before now his
attacks could occur anywhere across the
Northern Hemisphere making catching him
the world's largest game of whack-a-mole
but this was a game that Dr guys had
more than enough patience to play over
The Following years Dr guys worked as
hard as humanly possible not just at the
case of scp-4666 but at every piece of
work the foundation had to offer him
much like his ruined childhood guys made
no effort to interact no effort to form
social connections he just worked and
worked and worked and worked with
single-minded passion soon developing a
reputation as one of the most
hard-working and dependable figures in
the SCP foundation's European division
it was this kind of work ethic that soon
saw him promoted to senior researcher
and then a site director he had more
control over information resources and
Manpower than ever before it was almost
time he could sense it delegating other
tasks to his subordinates Dr guys began
to work on his Masterpiece an advanced
algorithm connecting police social media
and surveillance databases across the
Northern Hemisphere you see while Dr
guys had never faltered in his quest
neither had the Yule man every year more
families disappeared or were
horrifically murdered and every death
weighed on guys he saw them as a
personal failing of his of his inability
to fulfill his Destiny but the eule man
was a creature of habit and it would be
that very adherence to Habit that guys
use to destroy it using the algorithm he
created they would perfectly track and
triangulate the home most likely to be
the subject of a dreaded huisnacht event
with greater accuracy and precision than
ever before the year was 2022. Dr Geiss
was convinced that this time he would be
the one to claim victory and Vengeance
there was one thing he didn't tell his
foundation compatriots though as he put
the pieces in place for the final
showdown he had no intention of
containing the Yule man this time he
would destroy it using his Newfound
influence as a well-respected site
director he request did the transfer of
a few high-profile anomalies as well as
the services of a cracked mobile task
force death squad it was time the eule
man watched the house from a distance
he'd been observing for days watching
the nice happy family within what
pleasure it would bring him to destroy
them and take what's left to his
workshop for further fun tonight would
be the night that he claimed them they
were all blissfully unaware and lived in
an isolated rural area where nobody but
him would hear all the wonderful
screaming the second the lights went out
inside the house he would strike and
bring about some Christmas fear when the
last window went dark the Yule man drew
a long Rusty blade out of his bag of
tricks and approached the house he crept
in through one of the windows lox had
never been a problem for him this whole
process had played out hundreds of times
he barely even needed to think about it
now he crept in past the presence Around
The Christmas Tree found the stairs and
began and to climb he'd find them in
their beds one by one and take his time
savoring the pain savoring the fear he
went into the youngest one's bedroom
first his lips pulled back into a manic
grin there was the little boy tucked in
under his quilt like a present waiting
to be unwrapped he grabbed the sheet
with his long gnarled fingers and pulled
it back only to see a plastic dummy
underneath with a stun grenade fixed to
its chest before the eule man could even
react the stun grenade exploded into his
face blinding him with a sudden white
light and ringing in his ancient ears
the next thing he heard was a rugged
military voice yelling Squad Alpha move
it seconds later the upstairs Landing
was filled with mobile task force
operatives with assault rifles they
aimed an open fire into the Yule man
peppering him with painful bullets he
wasn't used to his victims fighting back
like this truthfully it even caught him
off guard but sadly for those Brave task
force operatives it would not be enough
to kill him the eule man gripped his
Rusty knife and lunged at Squad Alpha
moments later they were all dead and the
Furious Yule man was trudging back down
the stairs there had been no
satisfaction in this Slaughter how they
caught him like this perhaps he'd go eat
some of his servants in his Workshop to
make himself feel better as he walked
back across the living room past the
Christmas tree past all the presents the
television flickered into life staring
at him from the screen was the grinning
face of Dr ccleed guys now 50 years old
and the most insane part was that the
Yule man somehow recognized him the one
who got away 41 years prior hello old
friend you're looking a little glum
Siegfried said on the screen I take it
that you did not enjoy the surprise
party I just threw for you don't worry
the night isn't over yet after all you
haven't even opened your presents with
that the presence under the tree which
were actually packed with C4 plastic
explosives detonated leveling the entire
house with the Yule man still inside the
explosion could be heard for Miles as a
great pillar of smoke rose up into the
air several hundred meters away Dr seed
three guys waited and watched flanked by
Foundation agents and more mobile task
force soldiers taking in the Majesty of
the explosion Dr guys remained
steely-eyed and watch The Blaze somehow
he knew that even that would not be
enough to end the monster permanently he
nodded to the lieutenant he brought with
him squat out Squad Bravo time to engage
the man barked in response the remaining
agents and MTF operatives armed with
assault rifles and submachine guns
descended on the burning wreckage of the
house moments later a tall dark figure
the Yule man injured but alive crawled
out of the blaze immediately the team
opened fire giving the monster
everything they had but once again
everything was not enough the creature
pulled out two long Rusty knives and
leaped Into The Fray making short work
of the foundation brass soon enough it
stood alone on blood-stained snow until
it caught another bullet in the head Dr
Sid three guys was standing there The
Last One Alive to face the Yule man
leveling a revolver the eulman scowled
guys held his Steely gaze we meet again
at long last
Siegfried said you killed my family
you've killed so many others tonight it
is your turn your man this is you always
knocked Guys open fire as the old man
charged towards him taking each shot in
stride even as the Yule man closed the
distance guys didn't Flinch his resolve
was Steely it made the Yule man feel
confused and Furious that he didn't
detect an ounce of fear in this man even
when he drove a knife into the psych
director's stomach Siegfried dropped to
his knees and collapsed as the Yule man
ripped the knife back out his gun
clattered to the ground it had been a
mortal blow and still he seemed unfazed
why aren't you afraid the old man
growled Siegfried spat blood and said
you took my family 41 years ago
everything since then has just been
killing time until I got to see them
again
where you're going all you'll ever see
are flames and torment the old man
Furious stabbed Siegfried again this
time through the heart the doctor was
dying his life's work having seemingly
amounted to nothing but with the last of
his strength he reached into his coat
and pulled out something a little gift
he'd requested from one doctor Alto
cleff before putting his plan into
action Dr Siegfried guys lifted a photo
of
scp-096 right in front of the eule Man's
eyes Mary Christmas he said with his
last breath the eule man was confused a
photograph was that it was that really
this foolish little boy's trump card
after all this time what a waste then
without a moment's warning
scp-096 barreled into the Yule man
sending them both rolling across the
snow one of siegfried's preparations was
to have
scp-096's containment Cube temporarily
relocated to only a mile away from the
Ambush site to avoid collateral damage
if everything else failed then scp-096
would be their Hail Mary pass their
finishing move and it worked marvelously
as strong and evil as the eule man was
he'd been weakened by the night's battle
and the shy guy was an order of
magnitude more powerful than his
sadistic foe the Yule man screamed in
horror as scp-096 set upon him with
claws and teeth after hundreds of years
inflicting it others the eule man had
died in Terror and Dr seek played guys
had died with a smile on his face
there's never a good day for a super
villain attack or a tense Feud with your
closest sibling and for the Mighty Thor
this day was turning out to be both as
the self-proclaimed strongest Avenger
flung his body across the planet Earth
using his trusty Magical Hammer Monier
the Asgardian steeled himself for yet
another confrontation with his evil
half-brother Loki the god of Mischief as
per usual Loki was terrorizing the
humans of a random City using his
allusions to manifest imaginary dragons
and other ferocious beasts and what was
also usual is Thor had no idea what his
brother's motive or endgame was all the
God of Thunder knew was that this kind
of trickery decree would not be stood
for while these terrible creatures
weren't real they were still very
frightening to the earthlings civilians
were running around in every direction
away from Loki and this was causing all
kinds of chaos and traffic disturbances
regardless of what Loki's plan was Thor
knew that his brother had to be stopped
before things escalated further on Earth
humans needed to rely on vehicles to get
around and even the slightest
inconvenience in transportation could
lead to disaster Thor touched down in
the same City Square where Loki was
unleashing his horde of Make-Believe
monsters Landing in a classically cool
superhero way hello brother Thor
proclaimed I don't suppose you'll be
stopping this without a fight Loki
smiled a mischievous smile and replied
Arthur we meet again and once again
you're wrong I can stop this anytime I
want Loki swiftly moved his hand through
the air casting a new spell to dismiss
his diabolical decoys the Illusions
dispersed naturally and soon the two
brothers were facing each other one on
one see
Loki chuckled Thor was rightly confused
by his brother's unpredictable actions
he pointed molnir towards Loki in an
accusatory manner no Illusions no
sorcery what are you really playing at
Loki said Thor and then Loki reached
into his robes and produced an unusual
cube-shaped object as his good brother
was all too aware this particular Cube
was the latest in the long line of
mysterious and Powerful cubes that Loki
had used for his various evil plans Loki
juggled the unknown Cube from one hand
to the other then waved it in the air in
front of Thor and began to laugh
maniacally all I need to do is open this
ancient box of mysteries and I'll become
completely Unstoppable don't you dare do
it Loki Thor shouted that sort of power
will be misused in your hands that's
precisely the point Loki continued to
laugh then Reach For What appeared to be
the lid of the cube he grabbed the top
of it and made a show of beginning to
twist this and Thor's heroic instincts
into high gear and he threw molnir at
the cube knocking it out of Loki's grasp
as the cube flew away from the grinning
villain Thor Dove to retrieve it before
his brother had the chance he soon held
the strange item in one hand while
calling molnir back to the other as Thor
stared at the cube pondering its purpose
Loki stretched out his hands in
desperation oh no not by Cube if you
open it now my plan is doomed Loki
pleaded Thor responded with a laugh of
his own nice try brother but I'm going
to open it and so the God of Thunder did
Thor popped the Cube's lid and braced
himself for whatever Cosmic force was
about to be released but for some reason
nothing happened still curious Thor took
a cautious look inside as it turned out
the only thing within this apparently
non-magical Cube was what appeared to be
a fully developed photograph what an
Odin's name is this Thor removed the
image and held it close to his face it
appeared to depict an emaciated pale
humanoid with long spindly limbs
standing in the corner of a compact room
with smooth metal walls in all his many
years traveling the nine Realms Thor had
never seen anything like it whatever the
creature actually was it certainly did
not look happy of course what Thor was
actually looking at was a photo taken of
scp-096 inside of its containment unit
at the foundation the shy guy as its
nickname suggested did not like having
its face looked at even via secondary
means such as photography or video
recording the anomalous humanoid sense
of Shame about its own appearance was so
great that a mere moment after Thor
fixed his Asgardian Eyes Upon its Visage
scp-096 began to stir in its containment
unit the creature wailed and covered its
face with both of its hands on its long
sinewy arms it screamed and carried on
for a duration of two minutes after
which point scp-096 sprinted towards the
steel walls of its containment unit and
smashed through reaching speeds greater
than most Motor Vehicles
scp-096 began to zero in on Thor's
location as was always the case when
another being saw its face the shy guy
was compelled to utterly annihilate the
offending Observer with its bare hands
Thor himself had no idea that scp-096
was in route and continued to squint at
the photograph perplexed by the
mysterious entity depict therein Loki
now resumed his mad laughter because
once more he had managed to trick his
foolish brother into falling for one of
his ingenious schemes make sure to get a
good look brother Loki gloated yes look
at the full creature that will bring
about your inevitable destruction Thor
was annoyed if you think that showing me
a gross picture of some lowly wretch
will strike fear into my heart you've
truly forgotten what it means to be an
Asgardian save your sentiments for the
halls of alhala the Green Cloud evildoer
cackled you'll be there soon enough and
with that Loki used a charm to turn
himself invisible and vanish completely
from Thor's sight Thor stomped his foot
on the ground angrily he wasn't sure how
but it seemed as though Loki had gotten
the last laugh once again Loki he
shouted after his brother come back here
and face me with honor then the God of
Thunder sighed pensively and thought to
himself who am I kidding he's never
going to change Thor looked at his
trusty Hammer Mo and your old friend it
seems like we've saved the day yet again
shall we away back to Avengers HQ he
then shook Moneer up and down like a
puppeteer simulating a nod Splendid idea
ammonia glad you thought of it Thor
chuckled already in better spirits
that's when he began to hear the
footsteps of scp-096 rapidly approaching
him Thor turned his head towards the
sound and saw the same disquieting
Creature from the photograph that was
inside Loki's Cube zooming headlong
towards him with Reckless abandon the
Asgardian bling he almost couldn't
believe his eyes whatever that thing was
it was faster than Thor could have
possibly anticipated was it looking for
the photograph he wondered hello there
Thor called out his scp-096 continued to
make a beeline at the Caped superhero
the God of Thunder waved the photograph
of scp-096 in the air is this your um
selfie in all likelihood Loki had been
his usual conniving self and stole that
self-portrait from the miserable
creature hoping that it would mistake
Thor for the thief the god of Mischief
had probably even used a glamor to
disguise himself as Thor when he did the
deed Thor believed that all he had to do
was clear up this misunderstanding and
that he and this strange Beast could go
their separate ways without coming to
blows it was a naive optimistic and
ultimately incorrect view of the
situation but at least the hero's heart
was in the right place I don't need this
so Thor said trying to reason with the
creature you can have it back if you'd
like but scp-096 showed no signs of
stopping and was seemingly enraged even
further by Thor flaunting its decidedly
unflattering photograph the shy guy
kicked the ground and shot forward with
a powerful burst of speed one of its
elongated arms slammed into Thor's face
with enough Force to nearly knock the
Asgardian off his feet Thor was so
surprised that he instinctively whacked
the creature with molnir sending scp-096
careening backwards down the street it
wasn't launched more than a dozen feet
before its powerful arms and legs dug
into the pavement and slowed its
velocity to zero even though the thing
from the photo had taken a direct hit
from molnir it barely looked phased on a
physical level one thing was for sure
the shy guy was still incredibly
distraught and it was directing all of
those negative emotions towards the God
of Thunder what was this thing what is
this thing Thor wondered to himself it
was fast strong and durable to an
unearthly degree if this thing wanted to
engage in single combat Thor wouldn't
back down he was an Asgardian Warrior
and sometimes that meant facing
challenges head on no matter how
suddenly they arose still his time with
the Avengers had taught him that having
a clear reason to fight was sometimes
even more important than the fight
itself hey quick question
um what are you he said aloud to the
creature
scp-096 didn't answer within seconds it
was on Thor again like a build snipe on
another build snipe the screaming
humanoid swung wildly pelting its
opponent with blow after blow Thor tried
once more to communicate with his
unknown enemy I have no quarrel with you
weird one Thor smoke so take your noodle
arms and be gone for all of its
Relentless ferocity the humanoid
Abomination left countless openings that
a seasoned Warrior like Thor could
easily exploit of course most mortal
kombatants would be unable to endure the
brunt of the Shy Guy's attacks for long
enough but true to his nature Thor was a
god The Avengers struck back with
another crushing blow from molnir aimed
straight for the creature's sternum once
again the monster was pushed back for a
moment and then resumed its maddening
Onslaught a blow like that should have
at least busted a river too where the
bones of this horrible thing made a
vibranium or some other rare metal out
of the depths of space Thor realized he
was now fighting on the defensive while
he had faced foes in the past with much
greater physical strength than the shy
guy including his superhero colleague
Bruce Banner's mean green ever-loving
Alter Ego The Incredible Hulk the sheer
tenacity of scp-096 meant that being
careless with his own protection could
lead to Thor taking unnecessary hits
that would eventually wear him down in a
prolonged fight the ryrie humanoid
certainly didn't show any signs of
slowing down or tiring even though it
had to be expending a lot of energy to
move so quickly between his alternating
deflections and counter blows against
the the creature Thor mold over his
brother's words from earlier Loki was
right about one thing this is a fell
Creature if ever there was one still as
long as there is thunder in my blood I
won't allow a hairless curl like this to
bring me my own destruction thing for
what would Stark do at a time like this
he says he's the smart one after all
humor him with his highly sophisticated
tactical Acumen that was similar to Iron
Man except for the fact that it was much
better and stronger Thor efficiently
assessed his current situation while the
pale Beast was undoubtedly violent and
far mightier than most terrestrial
creatures its attention and all the
brute strength that came with it have
been fixated solely on Thor since it
arrived in the city the asgardians best
guessed as to why was the photograph
that Loki had tricked him into looking
at devious trickster that he is Loki
must have known that this thing would
hunt down and attempt to pulverize the
latest being to see its face which now
of course happened to be Thor the
revelation of this fact meant that Thor
no longer had to worry about the fate of
civilians if he chose to relocate to a
less populated Battlefield since the
creature was now guaranteed to follow
him nobody else needed to get hurt while
running from the fight wasn't exactly
the god of Thunder's favorite strategy
who would massively reduce the chance of
collateral damage he'd be saving lives
in classic Avengers fashion Captain
America would be so proud not that Thor
would have done it any differently even
if he didn't have the Star-Spangled
man's approval
scp-096 leaped in towards Thor to
deliver its next whopping strike but the
Asgardian quickly grounded by the wrist
and pulled the Ferocious creature off
its feet he lifted it up and over his
head before slamming it down hard into
the pavement with a bit of space between
himself and his anomalous foe Thor began
to swing molnir around by its leathery
wrist strap the shy guy desperately
scrambled to its feet to resume the
attack but by that time Thor had already
thrown himself Skyward he saw between
the buildings using the force of
molnir's trajectory making it his
mission to exit the city as soon as
possible Thor looked down to see that
scp-096 was following him along the
ground exactly as he predicted it would
well the battle with the Beast would
most certainly continue the second he
dropped back to Earth's surface he could
rest assured that the place where the
Showdown would take place could be
chosen by him he saw an evergreen forest
on a nearby mountain and decided that it
would do nicely as a place to finish
this I'm sure no one would mind a few
stray bolts of lightning around here
Thor thought the God of Thunder was
amused by the prospect of going all out
against this being even though it
probably had its reasons for wanting to
destroy the one that saw its face Thor
was past the point of Taking Chances on
diplomacy this distressing creature was
after all an adversary that Loki had
plotted to send after him through one
means or another and because of that it
was likely to have power and guile to
spare Thor breaking sweat to Vanquish
the thing would be a fitting replacement
for the fight that he would have to have
with Loki Thor's feet hit the ground on
a Stony Mountain ledge and once again he
struck that iconic superhero Landing
pose remarkably the shy guy had kept
pace with Thor almost the entire time
the Asgardian had been flying smashing
through every tree and Boulder that
stood in its path even so Thor was more
than ready for it storm clouds rumbled
overhead the sky above the mountain was
trembling as Thor decided that it was
time to bring down the thunder on his
unfortunate foe boom crack the heavens
flashed with electrical might as Thor
channeled the energy from several
lightning bolts through molnir before
unleashing a Consolidated blast of
unbridled power onto scp-096 the shy guy
didn't even attempt to dodge as Thor's
thundershock treatment bombarded it with
light and heat the likes of which few
Mortals could withstand Thor released a
second blast then a third surrounding
scp-0 0.096 with as much lightning as
these Earthly Skies would offer him
after keeping at this for a while Thor
decided to let up momentarily to check
in on his foe only to see that there
were no signs of visible damage on the
creature it wasn't even slightly singed
the God of Thunder could feel his
brother laughing at him from somewhere
out of sight and Out Of Reach the
Monstrous humanoid in the forest below
was proving to be far more than Thor had
bargained for but he was nowhere near
ready to give in and accept defeat still
maybe this wasn't a fight worth having
on Earth all Thor's electrical attacks
were doing was destroying trees and the
planet was already facing unprecedented
levels of deforestation due to the greed
of human CEOs and Shady entrepreneurs
Thor certainly didn't want to be part of
the problem and now that it was
occurring to him he realized that he
should probably try to do something
about that once the situation with the
shy guy was resolved it didn't matter
how close of a friend Elon Musk was to
Tony Stark these overreaching humans had
to be given a Stern talking to by the
God of Thunder with or without hammer in
his hand of course Thor's
environmentalist concerned had to go on
the back burner for now since scp-096
was advancing towards him once again
with no hint of slowing down let's see
if you can follow me back to Asgard you
son of an elf Thor thought he held his
hammer Aloft and counted on hemdel to
deploy the bifrost the Rainbow Bridge
arrives seconds before scp-096's arms
would have reached the Asgardian and as
expected it instantly carried Thor into
the interdimensional space between his
destinations amidst the swirling sea of
multicolored lights Thor shared a laugh
with nobody but himself and molnir so
much for shy guy said Thor looks like
he'll have to resolve those body issues
on its own time I've been through
something similar so I can relate best
of luck pitiful beast but while Thor was
congratulating himself for his strategic
Retreat he almost didn't notice that his
foe hadn't actually stopped in its
Pursuit as matter of fact scp-096 was
currently inside of the bifrost and
swiftly gaining on the God of Thunder
the shy guy was truly running in the 90s
well 90 miles per hour or more but it
made the same difference the creature
grabbed Thor by his ankles and screeched
in mortified rage Thor punched scp-096
in the face hoping to shake it off but
to no avail the two opponents spun
through the bifrost locked together in
an unbreakable grapple until they
collided with the walls of
interdimensional space Thor knew exactly
where this was going and he wasn't happy
about it like a sheet of ice composed of
photons the outer limits of the bifrost
broke away sending both combatants
shooting off into the void seconds later
a wormhole spit Thor and scp-096 out in
a vast junkyard filled with the remains
of countless spaceships and alien life
forms great I'm trapped in this garbage
world again I knew I should have picked
somewhere closer Thor shook off the
nauseating effects of the failed
interdimensional trip
scp-096 was already hail and Hardy for
another round Thor grimaced with
frustrated anticipation uh how about a
quick five-minute rest Thor implored the
shy guy gentleman Strauss scp-096 Ward
and dash fourth more crazed than ever
Thor exhaled in futility I thought not
he whipped molnir around and hurled it
straight for scp-096's skull the
reliable uru steel Hammer made contact
knocking the creature onto its back at
the very least Thor could always count
on his signature weapon to help him out
or could he when the Asgardian tried to
call the hammer back he was shocked to
find that scp-096 had somehow grabbed a
hold of its handle even more
surprisingly it now appeared to be
wielding the Hammer as easily as Thor
could Sonoma you're telling me that
thing is worthy the shy guy now with
molnir in hand pounced on Thor Swinging
The Hammer with no technique or finesse
it was everything Thor could do to
Simply avoid the creature's range of
Blow from molnir was enough to cause
serious injury to even the most
formidable Asgardian Warrior Damu Monier
we talked about this Thor Thunder we're
friends aren't we but none of his words
could get through to the Hammer now that
it was in the hand of
scp-096 in an act of righteous Defiance
Thor called The Fury of lightning into
his own body this strange foe which had
come from Loki's latest prank was about
to find out what happened when a god of
thunder got serious with the speed of a
lightning bolt Thor flew at scp-096 and
punched it so hard that it script
loosened on molnir for all but a second
and that second was all Thorn needed to
reclaim his weapon his hand clung
tightly to molnir's handle as he swung
the weapon into the Shy Guy's body with
all of his might the Shockwave of this
forceful blow launched piles of debris
High into the air and sent scp-096
tumbling across the surface of the
planet like a throned piece of discarded
food at an Asgardian Feast with another
pulse of electricity Thor magnetized the
portions of the rubble which contain
spaceship parts and used his
manipulation of that same energy to bury
the shy guy in the deepest heap of trash
he could manage and with one last flick
of Monir Thor sent himself hurtling
through the largest wormhole in the sky
above and back into space where it would
be far more difficult for his foe to
follow him finally with some distance
Thor breathed to sigh of relief you
almost had me that time Loki what an
unusual being fought like a Berserker
but was somehow also pure of heart the
kindred spirit to myself perhaps even so
I truly hope to never meet that thing
again everyone in the Sleepy Mountain
Town had heard stories about the
abandoned mall and the malevolent
creature that lurked in the wreckage
there there had been enough missing
persons cases lost children teenagers
sneaking out to explore and never
returning home Urban explorers who
stumbled out of the darkness disheveled
and traumatized with an eyewitness
account no one wanted to believe there
wasn't anyone left in the surrounding
area willing to set foot in that cursed
place but that didn't stop opportunistic
out-of-towners from paying the
occasional visit especially if they felt
like there was money to be made in those
crumbling corporate walls Grant and
Jason the hosts of up-and-coming
investigative reality show ghostly
happenings were two such visitors when
they heard the rumors about an abandoned
Mall haunted by some sort of dark
presence blamed for The Disappearance of
local children they packed up their van
picked up their underpaid cameraman
Derek and headed straight for the
infamous building are you sure we're
allowed to be here Derek asked shakely
as he began filming nope Grant answered
cheerfully that's part of the fun Jason
laughed look man this place has been
left to rot by the city no one cares if
we're shooting some footage besides
worrying less about the cops and more
about the ghosts of them all grand grand
not funny Derek crumbled come on serious
faces were rolling Jason nudged his
co-host and the two snapped into their
on-camera personalities once a bustling
Center of suburban American life this
shopping mall has transformed into a den
of Terror Grant's voice dropped into a
lower register his expression intense
local swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home something
that doesn't take kindly to trespassers
Jason added a ghost a demon just an
urban legend that's what we're here to
find out Grant pulled out an EMF reader
which began beeping as he turned it on
ah there seems to be a lot of activity
in here already I'm picking up something
don't know if you folks at home can see
this put the meters going crazy Jason
exclaimed it was a fake meter of course
one that they rigged up to beep and
react when Grant press certain hidden
buttons but the audience didn't need to
know that they were tuning in for story
for spectacle not for the truth if they
wanted that they could flip over to the
nature Channel and watch some lions
chasing a gazelle on this show they were
chasing pure entertainment they
continued deeper into the building
taking in the massive echoey space the
dusty storefronts the beams of rotten
Woods strewn across the ground the rats
that skittered across the floor it was
the perfect creepy atmosphere maybe a
little too perfect a little too creepy
what was that Derek practically jumped
out of his skin spinning around to look
at something behind him hey stay on us
Grant snapped I saw something moving
back there Derek insisted it was a rat
Jason rolled his eyes there are tons of
them in here Derek shook his head no it
wasn't a rat it was way too big okay a
raccoon then come on get it together
we've been in way worse locations than
this remember that old tuberculosis
Hospital Grant shuttered God now that
was scary this is nothing well not not
nothing Jason elbowed his partner I did
a good job scouting this place right
grant was about to answer when his foot
bumped something on the ground he looked
down and saw a Polaroid camera next to a
long empty water bottle and a small
backpack oh man get a shot of this Derek
obliged while Jason took a closer look
this must have belonged to one of the
Urban Explorer types who came in here he
unzipped the backpack rummaging around
hey look photos tons of them he dumped
the pictures out onto the ground think
he got some Spirit photography done
before he bit the dust well might as
well see Grant joined Jason on the
ground sifting through the photos as
Derek watched anxiously boring boring
dear dog Sunset oh wait a minute he
stopped holding up one specific Polaroid
this is the money shot right here Derek
zoom in on this all three men looked at
the picture illuminated by the camera's
light it showed a tall long limbed pale
creature vaguely humanoid in shape but
at the same time distinctly not quite
human its mouth was stretched wide in a
wordless screech its eyes his bloodshot
and wild its long tapered fingers were
reaching towards the camera damn that's
spooky Jason laughed a bit of
nervousness creeping into his voice how
do you think he set this up Grant asked
what if it's real Derek swallowed the
lump in his throat don't be an idiot
grants golf but then from the outside
not 100 feet away they heard a scream
ears splittingly loud filled with rage
pain and animalistic Instinct it was
like nothing any of them had ever heard
before the scream was followed by the
sound of splitting wood branches
crashing to the ground and horrifyingly
the sound of something breaking down a
nearby wall what did you do Jason backed
away from the sound me you open the
backpack Grant shot back guys I think we
need to get out of here Derek watched in
wide-eyed Terror as two pale hands
ripped a hole in the wall in front of
them making an opening for that pale
hairless head from the photograph to
poke through all three men prepared to
make a break for it and run for their
lives but as soon as the creature saw
them it was already too late with
another scream scp-096 sprinted toward
them grabbing each man and throwing them
to the ground the camera shattered into
pieces from the impact and Derek skidded
painfully across the ground as he rolled
onto his side to try and push back up to
his feet he caught a glimpse of the
monster opening its mouth impossibly
wide and descending on his bosses he
really didn't want to focus on what
happened next but suffice to say there
was nothing of them left afterwards
Derek tried his best to escape but he
was no match for the brute strength and
speed of scp-096 from the moment he saw
its face his fate was sealed there was
no Escape soon the beeping EMF meter the
scattered photographs and the broken
pieces of the camera were the only thing
left of the crew from ghostly happenings
their devoted fans would never get
another episode but at least one being
in the abandoned Mall could rest easy
now
scp-096 was safe again no one was living
who had seen its face it slowly crawled
back to the hole it had made in the wall
ready to return to the forest and climb
back up the mountain there could curl up
beneath a tree and stay there for as
long as it wanted but as scp-096 reached
the hole in the wall where it had once
been able to see night sky stars and the
trees in the distance there was only
Blackness it was as if something dark
was stretching over the opening blocking
the outside world from view 096 reached
out a hand to push the blockage out of
the way but whatever it was slithered
away from the touch faster than the pale
hand could move the wriggling darkness
crept back into the building weaving in
and out of the shadows as scp-096
watched it curiously whatever it was it
hadn't looked at the creature's face yet
it wasn't sure if this thing even had
eyes the but then stretching out of the
darkness and into view was a garish face
with wide white eyes with massive pupils
a round nose and a wide wide mouth
stretched into a toothy Grimace that
might have once looked like a smile this
was the creature that had made the mall
its home the apex predator of this
biosphere and it was staring directly at
scp-096's face it's face with the shriek
096 flew into a Primal Rage clawing at
the cat-like creature but before 096
could reach it the thing was gone where
was it where did it go 096 roared
tearing at the floor ripping up the tile
and gouging long deep scratches in the
concrete beneath a sound in the distance
Drew 096's attention and it bolted in
the direction of the noise swinging at
any obstacle in its path as it went it
ripped down a banner advertising free
frozen yogurt samples crushed an empty
cell phone kiosk and threw a gumball
machine to the floor with a crash it
would rip the entire Mall apart if it
had to if that was what it took to
destroy the being that I'd caught a
glimpse of its face and disappeared then
096 could see it that face that
wide-eyed grinning face it sprinted
toward the face as fast as it could the
cartoon cat was looking at 096 not from
a place in the room but from behind the
screen of a television in the
electronics store window somehow defying
the laws of physics and reality it had
made its way into the TV 096 didn't
pause to ponder the logic of this there
was no room for critical thought there
was only the need to shred to consume to
destroy it burst through the window
sending shards of glass in every
direction and reared back to attack the
screen it was so focused on its singular
task that it didn't notice the long
black arms snaking across the floor
winding around its feet all of a sudden
096 lost its balance as its legs were
pulled right out from under it those
stretchy arms dragging it into the TV
screen itself when 096 regained
Consciousness it was in a place it did
not recognize gone was the inside of the
mall or the familiar forest and
mountains outside instead scp-096 was in
some sort of hand-drawn World a massive
house with a hallway that seemed to go
on forever lined with infinite doors
leading to who knew where the floor
tipped and tilted at odd angles and the
geometry made no three-dimensional sense
it was dizzying and deeply off-putting
scp-096 had no frame of reference to
compare it to but a human witness might
have noticed that this place looked like
something out of an old cartoon from the
days of Steamboat Willie and the like
scp-096 did not think such a thing it
only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
Place one that felt threatening though
there were no visible threats and it
knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its
face all along the walls between each
door there were clocks in the shape of
that horrible cat eyes ticking back and
forth with each second wide smile
mocking scp-096 as if to say try and
find me
scp-096 would not be discouraged was no
room in its mind for that sort of thing
there was only the singular goal of
finding the cartoon cat and tearing it
limb from rubber hose limb psychological
warfare would have no effect still
cartoon cat would give it his best shot
this was his world and he could do
whatever he wanted here cartoon cat
poked his head out through a random
doorway waving to 096 with one of his
puffy white gloved hands as 096 wailed
and began to give Chase cartoon cats
slammed the door shut only to open
another door down the hall and poke his
head out of that one he did the same
trick over and over jerking scp-096
around from end to end of the ever
expanding animated hallway after some
time passed however it appeared as cp096
was not going to get tired and was not
going to give up hope of catching its
prey it was time to end this cartoon cat
wrapped one long arm around
scp-096's neck restraining it against
the wall and began to squeeze Tighter
and Tighter but nothing happened
scp-096 did not collapse did not react
at all except to tear at the arm around
its neck until it broke free then it
returned to the Relentless Pursuit
tearing door frames apart pulling up
floorboards punching through walls every
time it dealt damage to the environment
the space filled itself back in an
unseen pen scribbling in the gaps in the
floorboards sealing up the holes and the
walls two powerful beings going back and
forth locked in a seemingly equal
matched battle cartoon cat tried to
destroy scp-096 in a myriad of ways he
tried to rip the Beast apart to snap its
neck to do any manner of unspeakable
violent acts it had done before with
great sadistic Glee but this pale
Abomination would not fold would not
break this wasn't going to be any fun if
there was no ending and if 096 kept
destroying one of cartoon cats fan
favorite pocket worlds that was quite
enough cartoon cat grabbed hold of 096's
arms and legs the creature thrashing
viciously as he did so and threw it into
the blank space just beyond the
Illustrated world back in the mall
scp-096 crashed back to Earth was about
to resume its search for cartoon cat
when suddenly a bright light illuminated
its face a police officer stood a few
feet away holding a flashlight excuse me
you can't be in here you trespassing the
officer started to warn but his words
were interrupted when 096 began to
scream soon he would be screaming too
that's right it's time once again to
activate the famedron 6000 our patented
machine that definitely wasn't developed
in affiliation with Dr wondertainment we
swear after recalibrating rebooting and
hitting restart our Infamous specialized
supercomputer is ready to bring you all
manner of Improv scenarios we'll
simulate encounters between the SCP
foundation's various anomalies and any
other character from any other Universe
you could possibly imagine here's a
question for you what do you think would
happen if scp-096 the notorious shy guy
ran afoul of someone he couldn't just
kill for daring to look at it what if
the scourge of the underworld battler of
demons and the Devil Himself set his
sights on
scp-096 well we're about to hit the
button and discover the outcome of
scp-096 versus the dreaded Doom Slayer
so you've heard the old philosophical
debate about a tree falling down in the
woods and whether or not nobody being
around to hear it brings into question
if it actually happened at all right
well let's reframe that one a little if
an interdimensional rip in the very
fabric of the time space continuum opens
up in an SCP Foundation secure facility
and nobody is around to witness it does
a six foot tall 360
hulking killing machines still emerge to
slaughter everything in his path it
turns out yes yes he definitely does
horrified screams and the loud bang of
shotgun blasts rang out through the
hallway as Foundation researchers ran
for their lives the Doom Marine had just
been unceremoniously dropped out of a
portal into a strange and unfamiliar
environment mere minutes earlier he had
been awakened inside a sarcophagus
within a facility on Mars in the year
2148. unfortunately doomguy hadn't had
the best start to his day given that the
base he'd woken up in was being overrun
by the forces of Hell itself thanks to a
rogue scientist opening up portals to
the underworld and allowing all manner
of demonic Abominations to come pouring
through so naturally when another portal
brought the armor-clad Demon's Lair to a
site run by the SCP Foundation the
intensity of battle had led to the
doomslayer believing that the
unsuspecting staff were actually all
demons in Disguise and to him the only
good Demon is one he got to send back to
hell in the most brutal fashion
imaginable he wasn't going to stop until
he torn through wave after wave of
foundation Personnel thinking perhaps if
he killed enough he'd be returned to his
previous Locale for more demon killing
as the foundation dispatched its
security forces and mobile task forces
to take down the Unstoppable force of
Carnage decked out in head to toe green
armor it seemed nothing they could throw
at the Doom Marine was enough to take
him down a hail of bullets rained down
on him from the mtf's weapons
ricocheting ineffectually off his
protective plating as he continued his
assault remaining tireless thanks to his
immense physical conditioning the SCP
Foundation tried and failed to contain
Dune guy they assumed him to either be a
new undocumented anomaly or a violent
and unhinged Maniac from the church the
broken God given his armor resembling
cybernetic augmentations and machine
parts grafted to his body along with his
arsenal of advanced Weaponry but there
were no enhancements no augmentations
made to the doomslayer he may have once
been mortal but centuries of killing
demons had allowed him to transcend
ordinary human physiology he did not
Tire never lost strength never needed to
eat or drink and was near enough
Immortal yet among all the chaos that
was on furling a solitary researcher had
just managed to slip out of the Doom
slayer's reach he ran as fast and far as
he was physically able the mobile task
force troops were getting eviscerated
and the Slater could easily tear through
the whole Foundation then fleeing for
his life the researcher had an idea
either a stroke of Genius or total
idiocy and a risky move either way he
would send an anomaly on the Doom Slayer
he turned to the nearest containment
cell a windowless room with a heavy
locked door hurriedly inputting his
security clearance code the researcher
heaved the door open and covered his
eyes with his arm it wouldn't have been
his first choice of SCP to send into
battle
scp-096's cell was the closest lumbering
out of its containment chamber on its
misshapen elongated legs
scp-096 scanned the area alarms were
blaring it was loud and frightening to
the timid albeit terrifying creature it
reached up to cover its ears in
bewilderment not that the researcher who
at Freda could see what it was doing for
one his eyes were still covered and for
another he was already dead thanks to
the Doom Slayer barging shoulder first
through a nearby wall and raining debris
onto the nearby researcher beneath the
visor of his helmet the Marine breathed
heavily panting but not tiring as he
looked at the pale skinny creature in
the corridor before him it was clutching
the sides of its head its huge jaw hung
as far as the Slayer knew he was making
progress his attack was working he'd
killed enough of these demonic imposters
that they were starting to reveal their
true forms although in all his years of
Bloodshed and being a Scourge to the
denizens of hell he hadn't quite ever
seen a demon that looked like the shy
guy not that it mattered to doomguy
before long it'd be dead like all the
rest the Towering stick thin creature
turned to face the armor adorned Warrior
and shrieked immediately overcome with
anguish having a full-blown breakdown as
it often did whenever someone looked at
it as the demon killer stomped down the
corridor towards it the Doom blade a
long Sleek razor sharp edge extended
from the slayer's complex where it was
mounted on his wrist he reached down and
yanked the ripcord on his chainsaw too
he was long overdue for a glory kill but
before he could strike at scp-096 the
shy guy moved with impossible speed
faster than even the Doom Marine himself
it zip behind the encroach
moving quicker than he could perceive
one second scp-096 was crying and
wailing in front of him but not even a
full second later the creature was
towering over doomguy from behind
scp-096 gripped the Doom blade and
snapped it with ease like breaking a
twig before reaching its other long arm
down and pulling the chainsaw from Doom
guy's hand the motorized blade was still
running as he clattered to the ground
cutting a hole through the floor and
falling down into the lower level of the
facility enraged as he very often was
the Doom Slayer reached both arms back
behind his head and gripped the
elongated torso of scp-096 the virtually
Immortal killing machine hurled the
creature over his head with ease thanks
of course to his immense strength
doomguy could lift objects far heavier
than most ordinary humans and carry
heavy weapons without tiring he had even
grappled hand to hand with demons
throwing the shy guy down the corridor
like hurling a basketball was no trouble
for the space for bearing slaughterer of
Satan's spawn screaming and Howling in
pain as cp096 crashed to the ground at
the far end of the corridor tumbling
over itself thanks to its long limbs
before landing in a confused heat as the
shy guy reoriented itself struggling
back onto its feet and standing up at
its full height it was instantly knocked
back down as the force of something
Struck it barring down on scp-096 the
Doom machine charged his signature
double-barreled sawed-off shotgun drawn
he was hardly leaving a scratch on
scp-096's pale skin despite the moderate
amount of damage the weapon was capable
of two shots would ring out reeling the
creature but not harming it then by the
time scp-096 managed to recover from the
blast the Slayer had finished reloading
in time to open fire yet again even as
the Doom Slayer raced nearer closing the
distance between him and what he thought
to be another demon for him to kill the
shotgun seemed to have little effect
against the shy guy at close range
stowing the weapon doomguy put all of
his focus and energy into his charge
heavy boots stomping against the ground
as he raced towards the shy guy still
stunned by the latest shotgun blast
before the creature could steady itself
this time it was struck by another force
a heavy object barreling towards it the
doomslayer shoulder barged scp-096
sending the pair of them crashing
through the nearest wall they burst into
a neighboring room with a doom Slayer
keeping a single armed grip around the
shy guy while repeatedly delivering
vicious punches to its gut with his
other hand not once relenting
scp-096 screeched in pain clawing at the
Slayer but unable to tear through his
impenetrable armor as they crash through
yet another wall
scp-096 did something it rarely ever did
in fact maybe something it had never
ever done before it ran away from
someone that had looked at it while the
creature was deeply secure and so
self-conscious that it would kill anyone
who saw so much as a photograph of it
they didn't often feel afraid but the
Doom Slayer this muscle-bound killing
machine that had brutally butchered
actual demons was so imposing so
threatening and so effective at
dispensing painful punishment that he
scared the fight out of
scp-096 sobbing with Terror the creature
zipped away using its anomalous speed
trying desperately to put as much
distance between it and the Doom Marine
as it possibly could but therein lay the
problem no sooner had scp-096 gotten
away from the scourge of hell then the
creature immediately felt the familiar
pull whether it was an inescapable
compulsion to kill everyone who looked
at it for the fact of the Shy Guy's
biology it could only distance itself
from the Slayer for a few seconds before
it reappeared next to him from the
doomguys perspective it seemed like the
creature was intentionally disappearing
and reappear
using its teleportation-like speed to
evade a volley of his attacks
scp-096 came at him again stuck in a
loop of trying to attack the Doom Slayer
for looking at it to immediately
regretting that course of action and
fleeing in fear of its hulking heavy
weapon toting Target doomguy Drew every
weapon he had in his Arsenal launching a
barrage of high explosive Ordnance from
his rocket launcher to try and kill
scp-096 the resulting damage practically
reduced an entire wing of the foundation
site to Rubble but still couldn't kill
the slayer's opponent meanwhile in the
moments that the shy guy temporarily
forgot his own fear for the doomguy it
managed to rush towards him swiping the
Marines various technologically advanced
armaments out of his hands before
instantly remembering why he was so
scared of the green armored force of
Destruction and dashing away doomguys
supply of weapons had all but depleted
neither he nor scp-096 were getting
tired out by their constant back and
forth they were locked in a stalemate
until the shy guy tried to get back to
its cell zipping away once again it
cowered in the corner reaching for an
old worn out paper bag that had slipped
over its head it sat down trembling
rocking back and forth in a fetal
position the shy guy was terrified an
overwhelming debilitating fear gripped
it fear that became pure dread as the
sound of heavy boots began to stomp
closer and closer kicking the steel door
off its hinges the doomslayer walked
into
scp-096's cell carrying something huge
in his hands it was one of the most
devastating weapons doomguy had at his
disposal capable of unleashing Untold
destruction The BFG 9000 without remorse
not caring that the creature seemed to
have retreated and was cowering away
from him the Slayer raised the powerful
weapon and fired an enormous ball of
green energy the blast engulfed the
entire room tendrils snaking out from
the energy projectile causing additional
damage to the surrounding area until
there was nothing left of
scp-096 now for another Showdown brought
to you through the animatron 6000 go and
check out Mandalorian vs scp-610 the
flesh that hates and could homelander's
ego crush the SCP Foundation to see a
super-powered psychopath go up against
the foundation themselves